O'CLOCK TUESDAY APRIL SIX
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE CAN START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE SO ALL THOSE
AUTHORS WITH BILLS IF THEY
COULD COME SO WE COULD START
OUR PROCEEDINGS. I WOULD LIKE
TO WELCOME EVERYONE HERE BUT
NOTICE A COUPLE OF PRACTICAL
ISSUES AS WE GET STARTED SINCE
WE'RE STILL CURRENTLY. UNDER
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME ORDERS
WERE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AS WELL AS
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE HAVE ONLY. A LIMITED
NUMBER OF SPACES FOR PEOPLE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
REQUIRE THAT MASS BE WARNED AND
THAT PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED AT ALL TIMES.
BECAUSE OF THESE. SPACE
LIMITATIONS WILL HAVE MEMBER
SORT OF SPREAD OUT OF THE DICE
I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH ROOM FOR
EVERYONE WITH THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BUT IF NOT THERE
MIGHT BE MEMBERS SEATED IN THE
FIRST ROW OF SEATS IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN THE DISTANCES. FOR
WITNESSES TODAY WE DO HAVE A
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM THAT CAN BE
UTILIZED. WITNESSES CAN ALSO BE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM BUT
NOTICE THE- WE'VE BUT WE WILL
MAINTAIN THE DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS MOST WITNESSES
TODAY WILL BE CALLING IN. IF
YOU'RE IN THE HEARING ROOM WE
ARE GOING TO MAINTAIN
DISTANCING AND IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THAT I
MENTIONED LET ME KNOW AND I'LL
ASK YOU TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. THAT THERE IS A
SPECIFIC MICROPHONE HERE THAT
WITNESSES CAN USE BUT WE ASK
THAT NOBODY TOUCH THAT
MICROPHONE TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY AND THE SAFETY FOR
ALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
COMMENT. VIA TELEPHONE. THERE
IS A PUBLIC TOLL FREE NUMBER
THAT NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. IT'S ALSO UP ON OUR
WEBSITE. FOR THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN THAT IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO- TO HAVE THAT
ACCESS CODE IS ALSO UP ON THE
WEBSITE AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
OH TWO. SO THAT YOU CAN CALL IN
AND WHEN YOU DO THE OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU YOUR OPTIONS AND-
WILL HELP YOU. I UNDERSTAND
WHEN YOU NEED TO INDICATE THAT
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK.
SO WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR WE'LL
START WITH OUR ITEM NUMBER TWO
THEN AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
MR GABRIEL. SO OPERATOR YOU CAN
OPEN THE LINES NOW FOR. AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IF ANYONE
WANTS TO BE ON THE LINE. WE'LL
START WITH THE- PRESENTATION BY
THE AUTHOR AND THEN MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION SECURE BILL WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER KAREN MEMBER I
WANT TO START TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MOMENTS
I WANT TO THANK YOU. AND YOUR
STAFF FOR THE HARD WORK AND
THOUGHTFUL ASSISTANCE ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU AND IF
SOMEONE ELSE COMMITTEE NOW
EXPANDING ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS HAS
BEEN A TOP PRIORITY MIND SINCE
I JOINED THE LEGISLATURE. IT
WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO THINK OF
CIRCUMSTANCES MORE COMPELLING
FOR EXTENDING THAT FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT THEN IN THE EVICTION
CONTEXT AND PARTICULARLY IN THE
MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
TODAY I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE
LEGAL DEFENSE AND EDUCATION
FUND KNOWN AS THE HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION FUND. TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RENTERS AND
HELP PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
BEFORE IT BEGINS. THIS BILL IS
BASED ON THREE KEY NOTIONS. THE
FIRST IS THAT EVICTION DEFENSE
IS KEY TO MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESSING OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME. AND MONEY FOCUSED ON HOW
WE HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BUT NOT ENOUGH ON
HOW WE CAN PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
FROM HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
INSTANCE. AND THE DATA MAKES
CLEAR THAT THIS IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON IN L. A.
COUNTY ON AVERAGE EVERY SINGLE
DAY TWO HUNDRED SEVEN PEOPLE
ARE HOUSED. IN TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN PEOPLE BECOME
NEWLY HOMELESS TWO THIRDS FOR
THE FIRST TIME. SO THE PROBLEM
GETS WORSE EVERY DAY AND THE
DATA MAKES CLEAR THAT EVICTIONS
PLAY A KEY ROLE IN DRIVING
HOMELESSNESS SO WE SURE WANT TO
SERIOUSLY ADDRESS OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AFFECTIONS. THE SECOND
NOTION IS THAT LEGAL SERVICES
ARE AN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE. AND
COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE. AS THE ANALYSIS NOTES
THE IMPORTANT TENANT
PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE PASSED
RECENTLY. ARE NOT SELF
EXECUTING. THEY REQUIRE
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THE LEGAL PROCESS AND OF LEGAL
RIGHTS. AND THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL PROVIDES. AND WE
KNOW THAT RIGHT TO COUNSEL
PROGRAMS ARE PROVEN TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS WE'VE SEEN THIS
FROM INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS. WE
KNOW THAT THEY ARE PROVEN TO
SAVE TAXPAYER RESOURCES. IN NEW
YORK THEY'RE EXPECTED TO SAVE
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE RIGHT TO
COUNSEL PROGRAM. AND IN LA AN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS FROM FOR
EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED. THE
STATE BE THEIR PUBLIC
BENEFITTED IN FORT FOUR DOLLARS
AND FIFTY CENTS IN AVOIDED
COSTS AND SO WE HAVE CAREFULLY
CRAFTED THIS PROGRAM. TO
LEVERAGE EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS
AND AREAS OF EXPERTISE. AND THE
THIRD IS THAT MEANINGFUL ACCESS
TO JUSTICE IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM. ENGRAVED ON
THE FRONT OF THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT OR THE WORDS
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER LAW. BUT
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE INVOLVED IN A
LEGAL DISPUTE WITH POTENTIALLY
LIFE CHANGING CONSEQUENCES
WHERE ONE PARTY IS REPRESENTED
AND THE OTHER IS NOT. THE
NOTION OF EQUAL JUSTICE CAN
SEEM ILLUSORY. AND IN THIS
CONTEXT WE KNOW THAT 90% OF
LANDLORDS ARE REPRESENTED
COMPARED TO ONLY 10% OF
TENANTS. AND SO THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. I WANT TO KNOW
THE REPRESENTATION DOESN'T
CHANGE THE SUBSTANTIVE LAW. IT
DOESN'T CHANGE LEGAL RIGHTS AND
DUTIES IT DOESN'T PUT A THUMB
ON THE SCALE. IT MERELY MEANS
THAT EVICTION PROCEEDINGS ARE
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE DECIDED
BASED ON THE FACTS AND THE LAW.
RATHER THE INABILITY TO AFFORD
AN ATTORNEY. AND SO THIS BILL
WILL HELP SECURE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN A MANNER THAT SAVES
LIVES IT SAVES TAXPAYER
RESOURCES. AND HELP OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM LIVE UP TO ITS HIGHEST
IDEALS. THAT'S PART OF THE
REASON IT'S SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF MORE THAN
FIFTY NONPROFIT COMMUNITY AND
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS. AND
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE
GREASY ELEPHANTS ON FROM LOS
ANGELES AND SASHA HARDEN FROM
INNER CITY LAWCENTER. THANK YOU
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BILL BEFORE WE- GO ON TO THE
WITNESSES WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
I'D LIKE TO STATUS QUORUM CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE. HERE
GALLAGHER HERE'S- CHAU. CHIU
DAVIES HERE GONZALEZ. HOLDEN
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
TELEPHONE I HAVE AND ALEXANDER
HARDEN. SAID SARTIN OKAY DAN
GROSS YELLOW PENZONE. SO YES.
WHAT. OKAY I'M GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS FOR SALE. I AM A TENANT
IN LOS ANGELES AND HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY
SEVEN. WHAT FIRST HAPPENED MY
HUSBAND AND I HAD RECENTLY
SEPARATED. MEETING MY SIX YEAR
OLD SON AND MYSELF WITH ONLY MY
INCOME AS A HAIR STYLIST. AND
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
MY NAME. BEING THAT I WASN'T
WILLING TO BREAK THE LAW BY
CONTINUING TO WORK. AND THE
NEED TO KEEP MY SON AND MYSELF
THEY FROM COVERAGE I WAS UNABLE
TO PAY MY RENT. I STARTED
SUBMITTING MY DECLARATION TO MY
LANDLORD. TENANT SEPTEMBER WHEN
I FOUND OUT THAT I WAS PREGNANT
THE ADDED STRESS. AND
UNCERTAINTY. I HEARD MY
DEPRESSION CAUSING ME TO GET
THE MEETING MIGHT. THAT IS ON
MY MARK FILE AN EVICTION CASE
AGAINST ME IN COURT. I THOUGHT
THAT MY SON AND MYSELF COULD
END UP HOMELESS IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PANDEMIC. WHILE PREGNANT
WAS TRULY TERRIFYING WHEN I
WENT TO COURT TO FILE MY
RESPONSE AND RECEIVE THE
PAPERWORK THAT I HAD TO FILL
OUT I SOON REALIZED I WAS IN
WAY OVER MY HEAD I THOUGHT
ALONE. AND SCARED. THANKFULLY I
FOUND LEGAL AID AND MY ATTORNEY
FILED A MOTION IN COURT IN
WHICH THE JUDGE RULED. THAT I
HAD AN EXCUSABLE REASON TEXT
GIPSON READING MY DECLARATION
AND ALLOWED ME TO STAY IN MY
HOME. THIS CAME AS AN IMMENSE
RELIEF TO ME. KNOWINGTHAT I
WOULD STILL HAVE A SAFE PLACE
FOR MY SON AND MYSELF. BUT THAT
I WOULD ALSO HAVE A PLACE TO
BRING MY BABY HOME IN JUNE.
THAT IS WHY I AM HERE TODAY. TO
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON THIS
BILL THAT PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF.
HAVE A FIGHTING CHANCE KEEPING
THEIR HOME. I DON'T KNOW WHERE
WHERE WHERE I WOULD BE HAD IT
NOT BEEN FOR LEGAL AID. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE. GOOD
MORNING TERM MEMBERS SASHA
HARDEN WITH THE INNER CITY
LAWCENTER TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE THOUGHT. AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IS AN INVESTMENT
IN CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY THAT
WILL HAVE BENEFITS NOT ONLY FOR
LOW INCOME RENTERS FACING
EVICTION FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE COURTS AND THE STATE AS A
WHOLE THE BILL ADVANCES A
PROVEN MODEL THAT IS EFFICIENT
COST EFFECTIVE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY SUCCESSFUL AND
EFFECTUATE INFECTION PROTECTION
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
PASSED BUT THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. FOR TENANTS LIKE
METHODS- LUCKY ENOUGH TO FIND
REPRESENTATION CO DETECTION
PROTECTIONS ARE MOSTLY WORKING
BUT FOR THOSE WITHOUT AN
ATTORNEY WE'VE SEEN TENANTS WHO
THOSE PROTECTIONS APPLY TO
EXPERIENCE A RANGE. OF
CHALLENGES TRYING TO ASSERT
THEIR RIGHTS IN COURT.
RESEARCHERS PROGRAMS THIS.
IMPROVE CASE OUTCOMES TENANTS
WHO GO ON REPRESENTED AT A FAR
GREATER RATE. RESULT IN A RANGE
OF COST SAVINGS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND EFFICIENCIES
FOR THE COURTS. I CAN IMPROVE
RACIAL EQUITY IN THE EVICTION
PROCESS AND HELP STABILIZE
FAMILIES RESULTING IN A RANGE
OF OTHER BENEFITS LIKE
DECREASED SCHOOL OPTIONS.
REMEMBER GABRIEL MENTIONED THE
RETURN N INVESTMENT FOR A
COMMUNITIES IN CONNECTION OF
RIGHT TO COUNSEL PROGRAMS. NOW
THE TIME TO MAKE THAT
INVESTMENT FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S RENTERS I'M
RESPECTFULLY- DR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATE NOW OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY WITNESSES WHO
WANT TO INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR A BI FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
WE'LL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE ONLINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK TO PORT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. THAT'S
ONE THING THERE ARE NOW. ONE
MOMENT TO SHARE. LIKE WE HAVE
ELEVEN PEOPLE IN Q. MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO ARE SPEAKING WORDS WILL
TAKE NAME AFFILIATION AND THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL WE WON'T
BE TAKING ANY OTHER TESTIMONY
AT THIS POINT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE LET ME STANFORD S.
T. I. U. CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING NINE
HUNDRED AND WITH WIDENING GROUP
ON BEHALF OF NOTHING
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI BRIAN A GUSTO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS WONDERWALL
COVER TO KEEP GIVING
COORDINATOR WITH ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNION
CARMINE IN SUPPORT OF FORTY
MAYBE THAT. MY NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS ALEX WORKS
WITH EAST BAY HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT. I
NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI REDUCE
WITH CORDELIA SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING NOW. CONSERVE THE IN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU BYE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING DIFFERENTLY FERRON WITH
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. LINE
NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MORE INCLINED BUT THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS GIOVANNA
MORALIS WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IN Q. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MEHRABAD UNIONS WITHIN ONE
EQUITY PARTNERSHIP AND
ANALYTICAL ACCUMULATE TRUST AND
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU WE'LL THEN MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE TO LISTED
DEBRA CARLTON OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. AND
CREAM THREE C. OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS BOTH ON THE TELEPHONE.
MISS CARLSON. YES GOOD MORNING.
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
DEBRA CARLTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION I CA DOESN'T OPPOSE
EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
TODAY BECAUSE WE OBJECT TO THE
IDEA. THAT LOW INCOME TENANTS
SHOULD HAVE A LEGITIMATE
REPRESENTATION JUST AS YOUR
WITNESS I DESCRIBED. BUT WE
OPPOSED BECAUSE OF WHAT WE SEE
IS BOILERPLATE DELAYS. BECAUSE
WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE YEARS AND
ETHICAL LEGAL ORGANIZATIONS
THAT USE THAT THE DELAY
OBJECTIONS HURTING PROPERTY
OWNERS AND GOOD NEIGHBOR
TENANTS WHO WANT TO LIVE IN A
PEACEFUL HOME. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS AND SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ALREADY
COMMITTED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO THESE PRACTICES.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S BECOME A
COMMON PRACTICE FOR UNETHICAL
TENDED TO TURN IS TO USE BORDER
PLATE PRE DRAFTED PLEADINGS TO
DELAY OF ACTIONS. SOME EVEN
FORGET TO CHANGE THE NAMES OF
THE PLAINTIFFS IN THE TENANTS
WITHIN THE BODY OF THE
PLEADINGS. MOST OF THESE PLANS
ARE EXACTLY THE SAME THE
REALITY IS THAT THESE MOTIONS
ARE USED TO CAUSE A DELAY NOT
BECAUSE THERE IS AN ACTUAL
MERIT TO THE MOTION. AT THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THESE DELAYS
UNDERMINED THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF AN EXPEDITED
RESOLUTION OF AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTIONS CAN LEAD TO
MULTIPLE COURT APPEARANCES IN
HEARINGS INCREASING COSTS AND
CONFUSIONS. HERE'S WHAT YOU
FIND WHEN YOU SEEK HELP ONLINE-
ONE WEBSITE ANNOUNCES STOPPER
DELAY OBJECTIONS NOW GET THREE
TO SIX MONTHS GUARANTEED IN
YOUR HOUSE THREE WITHOUT PAYING
RENT. ANOTHER ATTORNEY BRAGS
AND ANNOUNCES ON HIS WEBSITE.
HIS RECORD FOR KEEPING TENANTS
IN PLACE IS FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS WITH FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PAID TO THE TENANTS.
YOU KNOW EVICTION IS A HORRIBLE
LAST RESORT WE DON'T WANT TO
SEE AN INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS
BUT THE ANSWER SHOULD BE TO
GIVE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
ALLOW THESE TYPES OF BOILER
PLATE- PLEADINGS. IT'S
IMPORTANT ALSO FINALLY TO NOTE
THAT MANY RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNERS HAVE NOT BEEN PAID RENT
IN OVER A YEAR DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. IN THE END
UNFORTUNATELY THE WINTERS THAT
WE ARTS AND HAVE BEEN NEGATIVE
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC'S
BUTTON OF THESE OWNERS AND
TENANTS WILL LOSE THAT PROPERTY
TO FORECLOSURE. DELAY DOESN'T
PERMANENTLY HELP TENANTS IN THE
LONG RUN TODAY WE ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU AND THEN
MR DRESSY. YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS- CREAM
GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HERE K. WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON
EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHES THE HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION FUND TO PROVIDE IT
SEEMS FREE LEGAL SERVICES TO
TENANTS IN NEED. SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL STATE THAT PRE LEGAL
SERVICES SHALL NOT BE PROVIDED
TO HOUSEHOLDS WHOSE INCOME
EXCEEDS 80% AND MINE. HOWEVER
THE BILL THEN GOES ON TO
PROVIDE THE PALM LOOPHOLE.
STATING THAT IF FUNDING IS
PROVIDED TO THE FIND THAT KERRY
CAN INCOME ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS OTHER THAN 80% AND
BY THE MORE INCLUSIVE
REQUIREMENTS SHALL APPLY.
MEANING FUNDING COULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE FREE LEGAL
SERVICES TO TENANTS WHOSE
INCOME WELL EXCEEDS 80% DAMAI.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH THIS CALL
ISN'T NECESSARY AT THE BILL
ALREADY PROVIDES AN AVENUE FOR
THESE FREE SERVICES TO BE
ABUSED BY TENANTS WITH MUCH
HIGHER INCOME LEVELS. BY
PROVIDING THAT A SELF
ATTESTATION. WITHOUT PENALTY
PENALTY OF PERJURY YOU
SUFFICIENT TO OBTAIN THE
SERVICES. C. A. R. STANDS READY
TO BE HELP ONE BILL COULD
SUPPORT THOSE IN NEED. HOWEVER
IS CURRENTLY CRAFTING EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PAINFUL
COLD THAT WILL MOST CERTAINLY
BE ABUSED THEREBY DENYING
ACTUAL PENDANT NEED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN HELP.
BECAUSE OF THESE AND OTHER
CONCERNS C. A. R. RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING VOTE ON. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
IS THE TIME FOR OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR YOU CAN
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. IF THEY COULD
JUST GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT THEY
OPPOSE WE WILL BE TAKING ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY. A PRETTY
GOOD OPEN LINES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. THIS PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. LAPERRIERE WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. CHRIS PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE THREE
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOSH GOOD MORNING SHERRY
MEMBERS FELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. I
NUMBER FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWEET ONE MOMENT OF THE
CHAIR WE ARE HAVING A PROBLEM
OPEN ONLINE. ONE MOMENT. I
NUMBER FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M A
TEACHER MEMBERS CATAMARAN WITH
ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT BRADY
WITH MGM ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES IN
OPPOSITION. GET MEDICARE AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. RIGHT THANK YOU ARE
PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINES WE
RING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TRANSGRESS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. MR GABRIEL- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IT'S CLEAR THAT COVERED
NINETEEN AND THIS PANDEMIC- HAS
EXACERBATED THE EXISTING.
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AT THE LEFT LOTS OF
PEOPLE WITHOUT JOBS AND BUT THE
BILL STILL HAVE TO BE PAID. I
KNOW THAT WE'VE ALREADY PASSED
AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT AND SB
NINETY ONE TO PREVENT TENANTS
FROM BEING EVICTED FROM THEIR
HOMES AND WHEN THE QUESTION
COMES FROM OPPOSITION AS WITH
ALL THAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE DO
WE REALLY NEED ANOTHER BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS
THAT WAS PREPARED AND I WOULD
QUOTE. THE ANSWER IS
UNEQUIVOCALLY YES. LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FACE
HIGHER RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT
DURING THE PANDEMIC IN OUR
INCREASED RISK OF EVICTION. AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS GOING
TO CREATE AS YOU STATED A STATE
WIDE EVICTION DEFENSE PROGRAM
THAT WILL TARGET FUNDS TOWARDS
LOCAL LET REVEREND LEGAL
REPRESENTATION. FOR AT RISK
COMMUNITIES I APPRECIATED THAT
20% OF THAT IS GOING TO BE SET
ASIDE FOR THE COMMUNITIES- THAT
HAVE BEEN HIT THE HARDEST LIKE
THE INLAND EMPIRE AND CENTRAL
VALLEY. I DO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMENTS THAT THE COMMENTATORS-
THAT- LOOTED THEIR THEIR
THERE'S- FOR THIS INCLUDING
VERY SPECIFICALLY THE INLAND
EQUITY PARTNERSHIP. WHICH IS
WORK VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
COMMUNITY TO TRY TO AVOID THESE
EVICTIONS AND AVOID FUTURE
HOMELESSNESS- AND THE COMMENTS
FROM THE OPPOSITION I
APPRECIATE AND- WHAT. I DO
GATHER FROM THERE THE COMMENTS
IS THAT THEY DO AGREE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE FREE LEGAL
SERVICES. AS I SAY FOR ACTUAL
TENANTS IN NEED- AND MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS WILL YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LOOPHOLES THAT THEY HAVE
DESCRIBED. WILL BE CLOSED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO HELP THOSE
TENANTS THAT MOST NEED THE HELP.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY I MEAN WE'RE
ALWAYS COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH PEOPLE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AND CERTAINLY
ONE- YOU KNOW WANT TO HAVE ANY
LOOPHOLES IN THE BILL I THINK
THERE'S A TRADE OFF HERE. THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO BALANCE
BETWEEN EFFECTIVELY TARGETING
THOSE AND THAT'S VERY CLEARLY
STATED IN THE INTENT AND
SPELLED OUT. VERSES CREATING A
NET ON UNNECESSARY BUREAUCRATIC
OBSTACLES THAT WOULD PREVENT
PARTNERSHIPS A LOT OF THIS BILL
IS ABOUT LEVERAGE ABOUT.
ORGANIZATIONS BEING ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER I THINK
ULTIMATELY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO LEAVE IT UP TO A LOT OF
THESE. REALLY WELL RESPECTED
BLUE CHIP LEGAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE PUBLIC
COUNTS ON THE LEGAL A
FOUNDATIONAL LOS ANGELES. TO
MAKE THE DECISION TO HOW TO
TARGET THOSE RESOURCES THEY'VE
BEEN GIVEN DIRECTION TO TARGET
THEM TO THEM THOSE WHO ARE MOST
WANTED ALMOST A RISK. THOSE WHO
ARE ALLOCATING THOSE GRANTS ARE
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRED TO TED
TALLY KATE THEM A TARGET THEM
IN THAT FASHION SO CERTAINLY
OPEN TO HEARING PEOPLE'S
CONCERNS. BUT AGAIN HERE THAT
THE ISSUE IS NOT WANTING TO
CREATE UNNECESSARY BUREAUCRATIC
OBSTACLES THAT WOULD PREVENT
REALLY POWERFUL PARTNERSHIPS.
THAT WOULD LEVERAGE OUR DOLLARS
AND MAKE THEM GO FURTHER. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
FOR ALL THREE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER JUNE. THANK YOU- LET
ME JUST THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
MOVING FOR THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION A COUPLE QUESTIONS
FOR SOME OF THE WITNESSES- OR
SOME OF THE- THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. QUESTION
FIRST TO MISTER HARD DOWN- TO
SASHA I KNOW CALIFORNIA WE'VE
FUNDED EVICTION OFFENSE IN THE
PAST. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS PROPOSED PROGRAM. HAS
LEARNED LESSONS FROM THE PAST
IS BUILDING ON THOSE
INVESTMENTS WONDER IF YOU COULD
TALK ABOUT- EXACTLY THE
MECHANISM BY WHICH THIS WILL BE
A BETTER APPROACH THAN PAST
APPROACHES. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- IT'S TRUE THAT WE
HAVE FUNDED LEGAL RESOURCES FOR
TENANTS FACING EVICTION IN THE
PAST- AND PASS PROGRAMS WHILE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL- HAVE
STARTED. REALLY AT THE POINT AT
WHICH THAT KIND OF GETS COURT
PAPERS AND SO AT THAT POINT.
YOU KNOW PAPERS HAVE BEEN FILED
CASES ARE HARDER TO RESOLVE
PARTIES HAVE SPENT MONEY ON
FILING FEES AND THE LIKE- AND
THE DIFFERENCE WITH THIS BILL
IS IT REALLY ENCOURAGES AND
SORT OF LEVERAGES. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SET THESE PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN LEGAL A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT WE CAN DO
THE OPERATION EDUCATION- AND
REACH TENANTS FURTHER UPSTREAM
IN THE PROCESS- BEFORE EVICTION
CASES OR EVEN FILE- BUT THE
SENSE OF THE MODEL THAT WE
HAVE. IN PLACE IN LA WHICH WE
ARE TRYING TO EXPAND. AND BUILD
ON- WHICH IS THE NINE TO ALLOW
TO WILL WITH. NEIGHBORHOOD
GROUPS AND THE COUNTY TO DO THE
AVERAGE IN A WAY THAT'S BOTH
SORT OF CULTURALLY SENSITIVE
AND TAILORED TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY- IT CREATES A
CONTINUUM OF RESOURCES BUT
LET'S ATTORNEYS SORT OF
RESOLVED. CASES THAT DO GO TO
COURT MORE EFFECTIVELY- AT THE
SAME TIME AVOIDING. SCRIPTED
PREVENTABLE CASES. THANK YOU-
AND I DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE OPPOSITION AND THIS IS A
TOPIC OF DISCUSSED WITH THAT
WITH BOTH CA AND CA ARE OVER
THE YEARS. I KNOW THIS BILL
DOESN'T CHANGE THE RIGHTS OR
DEFENSES AVAILABLE TO TENANTS
IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE RIGHTS OF
LANDLORDS TO EVICT TENANTS
UNDER. A VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES OR WHAT THEY
MIGHT DO- BEFORE BEING ABLE TO
EVICT A TENANT AND YOU KNOW
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I THINK FOR
MANY OF OUR PERSPECTIVES. WE
THINK THAT- ENSURING THAT-
TENANTS ARE ABLE TO EXERCISE
THE RIGHTS THEY HAVE A
PARTICULAR IN THE CIRCUMSTANCE-
MAKES A TON OF SENSE. WE ALSO
KNOW THE STATISTIC THAT NGUYEN
ATTENDANT IS REPRESENTED THERE
ARE TWICE AS LIKELY TO RECEIVE
A BETTER RESULT. AND THIS IS
THE STATISTIC THAT REALLY. I
THINK IS AT THE HEART OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH
HERE. IT'S ESTIMATED NATIONALLY
THAT 90% OF ALL LANDLORDS ARE
REPRESENTED. WHERE IS THE FLIP
SIDE 90% OF TENANTS ARE
UNREPRESENTED AND SO MY
QUESTION TO THE OPPOSITION IS
YOUR PERSPECTIVE THAT- THAT-
THAT THAT THAT THE SITUATION
THE STATUS QUO IS OKAY- AND IF
YOU DON'T THINK THAT. DO YOU
HAVE A DIFFERENT WAY OF HOW WE
WOULD ENSURE THAT TENANTS ARE A
REPRESENTED BECAUSE IT IT IT
DOES SEEM THAT THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE INDUSTRY IS THAT THE
STATUS QUO SHOULD REMAIN- AND
TENANTS SHOULD REMAIN ON
REPRESENTED DURING THIS PROCESS
I WANT TO JUST UNDERSTAND IF
YOU A DIFFERENT WAY OF HOW WE
GO ABOUT- ENSURING
REPRESENTATION AND REALLY- IT.
EQUAL FOOTING IN THE COURTS.
THANK YOU MISTER TO ADD
DIFFICULTY WITH A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AS I
STATED IN THE BEGINNING OF. MY
STATEMENT WE DON'T OBJECT TO
THE IDEA THAT LOW INCOME
TENANTS HAVE REPRESENTATION-
ESPECIALLY FOR A LEGITIMATE
DEFENSE WHAT WE NEED TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT. IS HOW TO WE AVOID
SOME OF THESE- MOTIONS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY JUST A DELAY AND I GET
IT THAT'S A HARD THING TO DO-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE MEDIATION
PROGRAMS IN SOME AREAS. AND IF
IT'S REALLY JUST ABOUT DELAY-
KEEPING TENANTS IN PLACE
WOULDN'T A BETTER RESULT BE TO
TRY TO FIND A WAY TO. KEEP
TENANTS HOUSE PERMANENTLY- WITH
RED DOLLARS LIKE WHAT WE HAVE
DONE WITH- SB NINETY ONE-
INSTEAD OF MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS JUST. TO
TIE UP THE COURT SYSTEMS WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT NEED
TO USE THE COURT SYSTEM. BUT A
BETTER RESULT COULD VERY WELL
BE EITHER MEDIATION AND OR
FINDING. A DOLLARS- FOR TENANTS.
TO PAY THE RENT LIKE WE DID
WITH SB NINETY ONE. I THINK
THIS IS GONNA CERTAINLY BE AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION BUT YOU
KNOW FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- OUR
SOCIETY WE HAVE AGREED THAT IF
YOU SHOPLIFT A TOOTHBRUSH FROM
ALGREENS THAT YOU GET
REPRESENTATION BUT IF YOU HAVE.
LIVED IN YOUR HOME FOR DECADES-
AND BECAUSE THIS PANDEMIC
YOU'VE LOST YOUR JOB- YOU CAN
GET KICKED TO THE CURB AND- AND
FORCED INTO HOMELESSNESS AND-
AND SO IT JUST. STRIKES ME THAT
THAT FIGURE OUT THIS BALANCE OF
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
REPRESENTED MAKES SENSE I
CERTAINLY HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THE PERSPECTIVE OF.
UNETHICAL TENDED ATTORNEYS I
THINK- WE COULD PROBABLY TRY
OUT JUST AS MANY EXAMPLES OF
UNETHICAL BEHAVIOR ON THE PART
OF CERTAIN LANDLORD ATTORNEYS-
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT JUST AS
LANDLORDS ARE REPRESENTED
TENANTS ARE REPRESENTED AS
WELL. ALSO JUST NOTED SAN
FRANCISCO I AUTHORED. OUR
CITY'S FIRST RIGHT TO COUNSEL
PROGRAM IN THIS LANDLORD TENANT
CONTEXT AND IT HAS TURNED OUT
TO BE BOTH COST EFFECTIVE AND-
AND REALLY ENSURED THAT FOLKS
WHO HAVE- HAVE RIGHTS. THAT
SHOULD BE VINDICATED- ARE ABLE
TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES- AND
WE'VE SEEN IT WORK IN OUR CITY-
BUT WE KNOW THAT- THERE ARE
LITERALLY- IT TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF TENANTS. EVERY DAY WHO DO
NOT HAVE SIMILAR ABILITY TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES SO WITH.
OPEN AND HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH
THE AUTHOR AND- AND- IN THE
OPPOSITION TO FIGURE OUT IF
THERE'S A WAY. TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD IF YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
SIMEON FACE VALUE GOOD FAITH
THAT PEOPLE DO AGREE THAT THAT
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED
TO BE REPRESENTED AB WHAT THAT-
I DO HOPE THIS MEASURE PASSES
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND- WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS ROBUST
CONVERSATION. DURING THIS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. THANK YOU
I DO HAVE A MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND. THANK YOU AND MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU- SHARE AND
THANK YOU DECEMBER GABER FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD I WANNA
SECOND THE COMMENTS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
SOMEONE THAT'S REPRESENTED
TENANTS IN LANDLORD TENANT
COURT- I COMPLETELY AGREE-
THAT- THE NATURE OF WHAT A
TENANT FACES. THIS IS NOT AN
ORDINARY CONTRACT THIS IS THEIR
HOME. AND I THINK THAT THEY
THINK THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
MANY THOUSANDS THAT THAT ARE
GOING EVERY WEEKEND TO. COURT
MINUTE IN THIS IMBALANCE OF
POWER REPRESENTATION- IS UNJUST
AND I THINK THERE IS A BALANCE
THAT WE CAN FIND TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE'RE NOT UP IN ANY WAY.
FEEDING INTO SOME UNSCRUPULOUS
ASPECT. OF REPRESENTATION BUT
TRUST ME AS SOMEONE THAT'S DONE
THAT WORK AND KNOWS PLENTY OF
OTHERS THAT DO THAT WORK BUT
MANY OF WHICH WORK FOR. LAW
SCHOOL CLINICS OR NON PROFITS
ARE DOING THE WORK- MOST OF
THOSE IN THE INDUSTRY THAT
REPRESENTING TENANTS ARE ARE
DOING IT- IT LITERALLY TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES SO I
APPRECIATE IT- AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. FOR
THE AUSTEN'S COMIC. THANK YOU
MR GABRIEL FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I. IN IN THE ESPECIALLY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY IT IT'S
INTERESTING HOW UNETHICAL
ATTORNEYS KIND OF ROLLS OFF THE
TONGUE BUT IN A COMMITTEE LIKE
THIS WHICH IS MOSTLY ATTORNEYS
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE ARE
MECHANISMS TO ADDRESS. ETHICAL
BEHAVIOR AND I'M ALSO STRUCK BY
THE COMPLAINT THAT A LOT OF THE
PLEADINGS ARE DONE FOR ME
LATELY AND DONE INFORMS. THAT'S
JUST BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
OF THEM THAT IT'S AN EFFICIENCY
MEASURE WHICH IS WHY LEASES.
MOST DOCUMENTS IN REAL ESTATE
TRANSACTIONS ARE ALSO DONE ON
PRE PRINTED FORMS BECAUSE
THEY'RE IT'S AN EFFICIENT WAY
OF DOING BUSINESS THAT THAT'S
HARDLY A COMPLAINT HERE. AND
SOME OF WHAT WAS. MENTIONED ARE
POTENTIALLY GROUNDS FOR
MALPRACTICE SO THERE ARE
MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO ADDRESS
IT THAT'S NOT REALLY THE REASON
AND THIS COMMITTEE HAS LONG
STOOD UP. FOR THE NEED FOR
FUNDING LEGAL SERVICES AT IT
HAS BEEN WOEFULLY INADEQUATE
OVER THE YEARS AND WITH THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
SERIOUSLY CUTTING BACK. FUNDING
FOR LEGAL SERVICES THIS WILL
REMAIN A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE FOR
THIS COMMITTEE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AS WELL AS BUDGETS OF
FIVE. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IS ABOUT
GETTING AN ATTORNEY IN
APPROPRIATE PLACES WHICH IS WHY
I THINK THIS IS A VERY.
APPROPRIATE BELT RIGHT THANK
YOU- MR GABRIEL YOU MAKE
CLOTHES YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CARE FOR THOSE COMMENTS AND
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THE FOR THE THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS
ALL JUST SAY. A COUPLE THINGS
ONE OBVIOUSLY VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THIS DIALOGUE WITH
THE OPPOSITION IF THERE ARE
WAYS THAT WE CAN STRENGTHEN
THIS PROPOSAL MAKE IT WORK FOR
EVERYBODY I'M CERTAINLY VERY
OPEN TO THAT FEEDBACK AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. I DID WANT TO
NOTICE AS THE CHAIR NOTED YOU
KNOW THE ARGUMENTS. AGAINST
THIS PROGRAM ARE ARE REALLY
EQUALLY APPLICABLE TO EVERY
EVERY SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE'S
REPRESENTED AN ATTORNEY EVERY
CASE THAT I HANDLED AS AN
ATTORNEY IN PRIVATE PRACTICE.
THERE'S A DISPUTE ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF DISCOVERY ONE SIDE OR
THE OTHER IS Q. THE OTHER SIDE
OF TRYING TO DELAY THE PROCESS.
SO TO ME THOSE ARE ISSUES ABOUT
OUR CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE AND
THE RULES OF JUDICIAL
MINISTRATION AND NOT SPECIFIC.
TO THIS PROGRAM A PART OF WHAT
I THINK CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION IS ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES THAT THEY GAVE OF A
DELAY TACTIC WAS REQUESTING A
JURY TRIAL. THAT'S FUNDAMENTAL
TO THAT'S ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL DEFINING FEATURES
OF OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE IF YOU
LOOK AT ARTICLE ONE SECTION
SIXTEEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION IT TALKS ABOUT.
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO TRIAL
BY JURY. SO THESE ARE NOTIONS
THAT ARE DEEPLY EMBEDDED IN OUR
IN OUR IN OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
AND- YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE EXPRESSING CONCERN
ABOUT FOLKS EXERCISING
FUNDAMENTAL CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS. THE OTHER THING THAT I
WOULD SAY HERE IS WE HAVE A
REALLY UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
NOW. IF YOU LOOK AT THE WHAT
MONEY THAT'S COMING FROM
WASHINGTON DC BOTH IN THE
CARRIAGE ACT AND ALSO WHAT IS
BEEN PROVIDED FOR THE ROOT
MERICAN RESCUE PLAN. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
DOLLARS. TO BUILD UP. OUR RIGHT
TO COUNSEL PROGRAMS TO BUILD UP
OUR VISION DEPENDS PROGRAMS.
THIS IS POTENTIALLY A ONCE IN
A. GENERATION OPPORTUNITY. AND
THERE'S GUIDANCE FROM THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT THAT
SPECIFICALLY SAYS. THAT MONEY
FROM WASHINGTON DC CAN BE USED
FOR THESE TYPE OF PROGRAMS. AND
WE KNOW FROM ALL OF THE
INDEPENDENT DATA AND ANALYSIS
AND RESEARCH. THAT THERE IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY RETURN ON
INVESTMENT TO TAXPAYERS FROM
DOING THAT SO. WITH THAT I
WOULD. APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FOR MY COLLEAGUES AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED KOLEL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE AYE.
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NOTE SHALL
SHALL I CHU CHU AYE DAVIES NOW
DAVIS NO GONZALEZ CONSEILS I
HOLDEN KALRA RIGHT KALRA AYE
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
REYES. THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TEN
TWENTY MISREAD. ANNA SHE'S ON
HER WAY UP HERE I'LL TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
UNLESS SOMEONE WHO LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA IS
THEIR SECOND SECOND. HAND A
SECOND CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CAN SENATE- GALLAGHER HI CHAU.
CHOW I CHU. CHU AYE DAVIES. AYE
DAVIES AYE GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN KALRA. HOLDEN AYE KALRA
AYE KILEY AYE KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. SO THOSE ARE
BOTH BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS AB
NINE NINE THREE PATTERSON AND
AB TEN SEVENTY NINE GALLAGHER
WRITES ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TEN
TWENTY MINS FRIEDMAN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS ON PAGE TWELVE.
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO OUR
PREDECESSORS IN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED TWO KEY REFORMS TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS AT RISK
FOR FINANCIAL DEVASTATION BOTH
THE HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING ACT
AND THE FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES ACT WERE DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND DEBT
COLLECTIONS AND TO ALSO
INCREASED PATIENT AWARENESS FOR
FREE AND DISCOUNTED MEDICAL
CARE FOR WHICH THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE. HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA UNDER CURRENT LAW
HAVE TO PROVIDE CHARITY CARE TO
PATIENTS WHO RECEIVE MEDICAL
SERVICES AND ARE UNINSURED OR
UNDER INSURED THIS CONSISTS OF
FULL PAYMENTS ARE PARTIAL
PAYMENTS DEPENDING ON THEIR
PARTICULAR SITUATION. THE
HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING I
PROVIDES THE MINIMUM GUIDELINES
TO HELP HOSPITALS HAVE TO
FOLLOW WHEN THEY OFFER THIS
CHARITY CARE AS WELL AS HOW
THEY CAN GO AFTER ANY UNPAID
DEBT A DEBT COLLECTORS IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO HAVE TO FOLLOW
THE SAME RULES. IT ALSO
PROVIDES PROTECTIONS TO
PATIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
COLLECTIONS PROCESS THAT
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE A HUNDRED
FIFTY TIME PERIOD BEFORE A
HOSPITAL OR COLLECTION AGENCIES
CAN REPORT THEIR ACCOUNT TO A
CONSUMER REPORTING AGENCY OR TO
START CIVIL ACTIONS AGAINST THE
PATIENT. HOWEVER DESPITE THESE
PROTECTIONS AND DESPITE THE LAW
THERE ARE HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THESE RULES THAT ARE
NOT TELLING THE PATIENT ABOUT
THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR CHARITY
CARE AND THAT ARE ALSO SENDING
THAT THEIR INFORMATION RIGHT
OFF TO COLLECTION AGENCIES
WHICH IS A DEVASTATING TO THE
PATIENTS HI THERE HOW KAISER
HEALTH NEWS REPORTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. THAT
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA'S COULD HAVE BUT DID
NOT PROVIDE A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN CHARITY
CARE TO PATIENTS INSTEAD THEY
WERE AFTER THESE PAY. WERE
UNABLE TO PAY. FOR THOSE
SUPPOSED TO DEBTS. THE
PATIENT'S REPORT BEING DISHED
CHARGE ARE RECEIVING MEDICAL
BILLS WITHOUT KNOWING THAT THEY
WERE ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE. OR HOW THEY COULD
APPLY FOR CHARITY CARE. TO
ADDRESS THESE GAPS AND TO
PROTECT THESE VERY VULNERABLE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT ONLY.
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED BUT
A LOT OF TIMES OR THE WORST
TIME OF THEIR LIVES BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN SICK. SO THEY'RE
REALLY NOT ABLE TO FIGHT THE
SYSTEM SO THIS BILL WILL
STRAIGHT FROM THE STATE
ENFORCEMENT OVERSIGHT OF A
HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING ACT. BY
PENALIZING HOSPITALS THAT DON'T
FOLLOW THE LAW. IT WILL PROVIDE
PATIENTS WITH MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR BILLS
AND ABOUT HOW THEY CAN APPLY
FOR PUBLIC PROGRAMS LIKE MELIK
MEDIC CAL. AS WELL AS CHARITY
CAL AT THE TIME OF DISCHARGE
AND ALSO WHEN THE BILL IS SENT
TO COLLECTIONS. BUT IT'S
POSSIBLE SOME SELLING PATIENT
DATA SOMETHING THAT TOO MANY OF
THEM ARE STILL DOING. START
SELLING PATIENT DEBT. IT
EXTENDS ADVERSE CREDIT
REPORTING A COMMENCEMENT OF
CIVIL ACTIONS FROM A HUNDRED
FIFTY DAYS TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS AFTER INITIAL
BILLING. REMEMBER A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE ARE LAID UP AND
NOT EVEN ABLE TO OPEN THEIR
MAIL. REQUIRES DEBT COLLECTORS
TO CERTIFY THAT THE PATIENT HAS
BEEN SCREENED FOR PUBLIC
PROGRAMS AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE BEFORE THEY FILE A
LAWSUIT. AND IT RAISES THE
INCOME LEVEL FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FROM 310050% OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL 24100% OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL. FOR THE PAST FEW
WEEKS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING.
WITH A CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION TO ADDRESS ANY
CONCERNS THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE.
AND WE HAVE AGREED WITH THEM ON
A BASIC- FRAMEWORK FOR
COMPLIANCE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
IRON OUT DETAILS AS WE MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD INTO ASSEMBLY
HEALTH. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
THIS MORNING OR TRACY DOUGLAS
WITH BED SADEQ LEGAL SERVICES
AND MONIQUE DAVIS WHO IS A
PATIENT WHO WANTS TO SHARE HER
STORY WITH YOU TODAY. RESHAPE
YOUR THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION
AYE ORIGIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN I HAVE
THREE WITNESSES LISTED TRACY
DOUGLAS OF PETS ACT. MANY DAY
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL GEN FLORI
FROM THE WESTERN CENTER LAW
POVERTY WHO IS THEY'RE ALL
THREE ON THE TELEPHONE THIS
FLOOR IS AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS SO. WE'LL START WITH
TRACY DOUGLAS. MORNING THANK
YOU ARE WILL MEMBERS THAT
SENATE IS A NONPROFIT LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATION AND WE ARE PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR AB TEN TWENTY.
LET ME CLEAR CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS ARE NOT PROVIDING
CHARITY CARE WHEN THEY COULD
AND ARE ALSO NOT TELLING
PATIENTS ABOUT ITS
AVAILABILITY. MEDICAL DEBT HAS
DEVASTATING EFFECTS YOU CAN
SEND PEOPLE INTO POVERTY THEY
CAN LIVE THEIR HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND FOR CLOSURE THE
STRESS FROM DEBT PILING UP
COLLECTION CALLS FROM WRITTEN
HELP. ANYWHERE THINKING THE
FORCED TO FILE FOR BANKRUPTCY
MEDICAL DEBT IS THE LEADING
CONTENT. THE CONSUMER
BANKRUPTCY. EIGHT TEN TWENTY
PROVIDE PUT FOR PATIENTS AND
NUMBER OF WAYS. INCREASES
ELIGIBILITY 24100% A THIRD
PARTY LINE. I REQUIRED NOTICE
OF FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
POLICIES BY HOSPITAL IN DEBT
COLLECTORS EDUCATION. REQUIRES
DEBT COLLECTORS TO SHOW THAT
THE PATIENT HAS ITS CREAM FOR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE AND FIND
IT HIGHLY A LOT THEY- AND IT
BANNED THE SALE OF MEDICAL DEBT
TO DEBT BUYERS FOR THE
HOSPITALS RETAIN. CONTROL OVER
THE DEATH. MY CLIENT TO STATE
BILL ARE SENIORS WHO HAD
EMERGENCY CARE WE NEED
SURGERIES CURRENTLY. AND NO TO
THE HOT EVER LET THEM KNOW THAT
CHARITY CARE. THEY WERE FORCED
ENOUGH TO BE REFERRED TO LEGAL
AID FOR HEALTH. IT SHOULD NOT
ME AND IT'S TO THEM TRAINING
ISSUES AS AN OPTION. THE
FINANCIAL PROCESS NOT BE OPAQUE
HARD TO GET IT SHOULD BE
READILY AVAILABLE. THAT IS NOT
THE ONLY LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS NORTH A PROBLEM
MY COLLEAGUES FROM OTHER LEGAL
SERVICES REPORT SEEING THE SAME
ISSUE. AFTER ALL THERE CAN
COLLECTIONS THE PANDEMIC YOU
CAN EXPECT THAT MEDICAL DEBT
WILL INCREASE. THE TIME HAD
COME TO STRENGTHEN THE HOSPITAL
FAIR PRICING ACT SO THAT EVEN
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE AN
ATTORNEY BENEFIT FROM IT AB
INTENDED. THIRTY THREE CAN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE HAVE MONIQUE DAVIS.
I LIVE IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTY FIVE AND SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTY JAIL. IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH A RARE BONE
MARROW DISORDER I HAD NEVER
BEEN THERE BEFORE AND I WAS AT
THE TIME OF MY LIFE AND CAREER
I WAS TREATED OVER FIVE
SEPARATE HOSPITALS BEFORE I
WAS. BEFORE I WAS AT THE- PART
OF THE HOSPITAL AND RECEIVED
CHEMOTHERAPY AND A STEM CELL
TRANSPLANT THAT WAS REQUIRED.
MULTIPLE TIMES OWES US TO THE
HOSPITAL IN AN EMERGENCY. EACH
TIME I WAS ADMITTED AND STAYED
AT LEAST A WEEK OR MORE. I WAS
SEEN AT UC IRVINE. I'M A
MEDICAL LA PALMA THE COMMUNITY
MEMORIALCARE ORANGE COAST
MEDICAL CENTER ANAHEIM REGIONAL
WEST ANAHEIM MEDICAL CENTER. I
WOULD VERY. DEFINITELY SET FOR
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF. IN N.
OUT OF HOSPITALS AND NOT
RECEIVING CORRECT TREATMENT.
EACH TIME BEING SENT HOME
WITHOUT THE PROPER DIAGNOSIS
AND ACCUMULATING MORE AND MORE
MEDICAL THAT. I COULD NOT WORK
MY HUSBAND HAD TO TAKE
TEMPORARY LEAVE FROM THAT SPORT
TO CARE FOR ME. WHILE AT
MEMORIAL CARE THEY TOLD MY
HUSBAND TO BORROW MONEY FROM
FAMILY MEMBERS AND PAY OUT OF
POCKET BEFORE THEY WILL
CONTINUE MY TREATMENT. NONE OF
THE HOSPITALS INFORMED US OF
ANY POTENTIAL FINANCIAL HELP.
WE STARTED TO RECEIVE NUMEROUS
HOSPITAL BILLS IN THE MAIL AND
PHONE CALLS THEY WOULD CALL ME
WHILE STILL IN THE HOSPITAL.
THEY WILL CALL. MY HUSBAND AT
WORK AND DEMAND PAYMENT. WE
WERE SCARED ALSO AND- AT TIMES
THOUGHT NAY IT WOULD BE IF I
DIED. IN MY HOUSE WOULD NOT
HAVE. THE ADDED STRESS OF
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF ME. THE
BILL'S MOUNTED AND THE CALL THE
PRIEST THEY TURNED US OVER TO
COLLECTION AGENCIESAND
REPORTING NEGATIVE CREDIT
ACTIVITY. THIS HAS IMPACTED MY
ABILITY TO GAIN NEW EMPLOYMENT
AS A NONPROFIT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND SOCIAL SERVICES
EXECUTIVE. WAS IT MY FAULT I
BECAME ILL ISN'T. IT MORE MONEY
MORE IMPORTANT IN MY LIFE. IT
WAS NOT UNTIL I CONTACT THE
PUBLIC LAWCENTER THAT ACCOUNT
OUT THAT I SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN
HELP BUT THE HOSPITAL BILLS TO
REDUCE MY BILLS OFFER ME A
PAYMENT PLAN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION OF
BILL EIGHTY TEN TWENTY. I THANK
YOU IN WOULD YOU IDENTIFY
YOURSELF FOR A RECORD PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MONIQUE DAVIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. RIGHT SO WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO SUPPORT ON THE-
PHONE LINES I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
IN THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM
OPERATING COULD OPEN THE LINES
FOR AB TEN TWENTY FOUR. MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC WHO WANTED TO GIVE US
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR SUPPORT OF AB TEN
TWENTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN TWENTY. PRESS ONE TWO ZERO
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB. TEN TWENTY PRESS
ONE THERE THERE ARE NOW. THAT
IS TIMES THE CHAIR WE HAVE
THREE PEOPLE IN Q. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING YES MEAN COLORED WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
COMMUTE THE LAND WITH THE LEGAL
AID SOCIETY A CEMETERY COUNTY
IN SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
RETIRING WITH THE PUBLIC
LAWCENTER WHEN IT THE COUPON AS
EIGHTY TEN TWENTY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IT AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE I THINK YOU. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS. NOTED AND
THAT IS BARBARA GLAZER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WHO IS WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE.
MORNING. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE DO HAVE A POSITION OF
OPPOSED THE LAST AMENDED
HOWEVER HE HA DOES SUPPORT MANY
OF THE CHANGES PROPOSED IN
EIGHTY TEN TWENTY SUCH AS
INCREASING THE ELIGIBILITY
COMPORT CHARITY CARE FROM
310050% IMPORTANT TO PRETEND
THAT FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. WE
APPRECIATE MLA BEING TAKEN
TODAY AND COMMITTEE THEY DO
DEAL WITH SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
WE HAVE SOME REMAINING ISSUES
HAVING TO DO WITH OVERLAPPING
REGULATORY AUTHORITY AND THE
LEVEL OF THE PINE. BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE AND THE
FONG AND I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
WE CAN RESOLVE THE DIFFERENCES
TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. RIGHT
WE WILL NOW OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE MEMBER THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN TWENTY
OPERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TEN TWENTY FIRST ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
TWENTY FIRST WHAT'S ONE. ZERO
NOW. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. IT'S KILEY. GOOD
MORNING SO I AM MENTIONING IS
THAT YOU'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
CHARITY CARE SEES ME IF EITHER
YOU ARE UNINSURED OR HAVE HIGH
OUT OF POCKET COSTS AND YOUR
INSURED YOU KNOW- OR ANY OF THE
WITNESSES SORT OF WHAT'S THE
MORE COMMON SITUATION WHICH
CHARITY CARE IS USED AS IT IS A
PRETTY ON SHERMAN INSURANCE. I
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION-
MAYBE ONE OF THE MAYBE THAT
SETBACK- WITNESS MIGHT NOW.
JENNIFER LAURIE I CAN SPEAK TO
THAT ISSUE FROM WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY- WE DO FIND
THAT MORE OFTEN PATIENTS WHO
ARE UNINSURED ARE SCREENED FOR
CHARITY CARE BUT NOT ALL OF THE
TIME. IT CAN BE HARDER TO
IDENTIFY UNDER INSURED
PATIENTS. PARTICULARLY PATIENTS
WHO HAVE HIGH DEDUCTIBLE HEALTH
PLANS OFTEN WHAT THEY NEED IS
JUST AND REASONABLE PAYMENT
PLAN WHICH IS ALSO PART. OF THE
HOSPITAL CARE PRICING ACT AND
SO THEY HAD THAT INFORMATION
AND THEY KNEW HOW TO GET THAT
PAYMENT PLAN THEY WOULD BE
GREATLY BENEFITED. OKAY I GUESS
I BELIEVE UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
NOW RELEASED AS OF. THIS YEAR
LAST YEAR YOUR ACTION REQUIRED
TO BE INSURED AND IF YOU DON'T
GET INSURANCE THEN YOU'RE-
PENALIZED- FOR THAT BUT THEN WE
ALSO HAVE A POLICY WHERE YOUR-
GIVEN- REDUCED- YOU KNOW COSTS
IF YOU. ARE NOT FOLLOWING THAT
MANDATE AND GO TO THE HOSPITAL
SERVICES COULD TRYING TO GET MY
MIND OR HOW HOW THESE POLICIES
SORT OF IT TOGETHER. WELL I CAN
CERTAINLY CAN SPEECH EVERY CASE
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE MANY INDIVIDUALS WHO
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE.
AT THEIR HEALTHCARE THAT'S
EXCESSIVE THAT'S THE PORTABLE
FOR THEM- OR THAT THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE OR
MEDICAID ALL. AND SOMETIMES
IT'S A QUESTION OF THE
HOSPITALS PROVIDING INFORMATION
HELPING THEM SIGN UP AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT MANY OF THESE
HOSPITALS ARE NOT DOING.
THEY'RE NOT HELPING THEM
NAVIGATE THAT SYSTEM TO GET
THEM TO GET THE INSURANCE- BUT
IT IF YOU'RE ASK AT SO. AS TO
WHY SOMEBODY MIGHT KNOW ABOUT
INSURANCE. AND NOT HAVE IT
SOMETIMES THEY MAYBE FEEL THEY
CAN'T AFFORD IT- EVEN WITH THE
SUBSIDIES- I HAVE FOUND JUST
ANECDOTALLY THAT WHEN I'VE TOLD
PEOPLE ABOUT THE SUBSIDIES ARE
AVAILABLE UNDER CALIFORNIA A
LOT OF PM PEOPLE HAD NO IDEA.
THEY HAD NO IDEA THE AMOUNT OF
SUBSIDY AND THAT THE BUT THERE
IS INSURANCE OUT THERE THAT
THEY WERE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT'S
AFFORDABLE. SO I THINK THOSE
ARE SOMETIMES THE PEOPLE WHO
FIND THEIR WAY. INTO THE
SITUATION. BUT I'M JUST
GUESSING I. I DON'T HAVE THE
ONE ON ONE EXPERIENCE THAT
WESTERN CENTER MIGHT HAVE THEY
MIGHT GIVE YOU A DIFFERENT
ANSWER. YEAH THAT MAKES SENSE
TO ME DID YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING OTHER WHEN THE SUN ON
THE PHONE. AT I WOULD SAY ALL
OF THOSE THINGS ARE ABSOLUTELY
TRUE AND THEN EVEN FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE INSURED YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY LOSE THEIR JOB AND THEY
LOSE THEIR INSURANCE IT CAN
TAKE SOME TIME BEFORE THEY GET
INTO A NEW PROGRAM. OKAY LET'S
NOT MAKE SENSE TO ME I'M GONNA
SUPPORT YOUR BILL I JUST WANT
TO KIND OF POINT OUT IT. AND
SOMETIMES THE IRONY OF IT. YOU
KNOW WE'RE PROVIDING THIS-
RELIEF BUT THEN AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE WE'RE SORT OF.
FINANCIALLY PUNISHING THESE
VERY SAME PEOPLE- IF THEY DON'T
COMPLY WITH THE STATE'S MANDATE
SO THAT MAYBE SOMEONE WILL LOOK
AT SOME POINT. THANK YOU THANKS
FOR THE QUESTION. WELL WE ALSO
KNOW THAT EVEN THOUGH THERE IS
A MANDATE WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE. THAT WE'RE NOT COVERING
THREE OR FOUR MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA SO. THERE IS NOT
COMPLETE COVERAGE. FOR THE
GOVERNOR WHO MAY BE SUBJECT TO
THIS SO. SORRY AND THAT GAP IS
LARGE I HAVE I HAVE BLUE CROSS
YEARS AGO PRETTY GOOD INSURANCE
PLAN AND WHEN I WENT WENT
THROUGH A YEAR OF CHEMOTHERAPY
I ENDED UP WITH TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN DEBT. AND IT WAS NOT
POSSIBLE IT IS REALLY HARD FOR
ME TO PAY THAT SO EVEN PEOPLE
THAT HAVE SUPPOSEDLY GOOD
INSURANCE GOING VERY HIGH OUT
OF POCKET COSTS. IT'S A TRAP.
IT OUT. I JUST WANT TO GAUGE
SIZE AND THE- OF THE PROBLEM.
NOW IF- MAYBE A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS FOR THE-
WITNESSES. A FOOTFALL- THE ACT-
THAT IS THE- OF THIS
PARTICULAR. ALL OF THE HOSPITAL
FAIR PRICING ACT APPLIES TO
BOTH. NONPROFIT HOSPITALS AS
WELL AS A FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS
IS THAT CORRECT. I BELIEVE SO
OKAY. NOW IT'S BEEN CITED THAT-
IN TWENTY NINETEEN- THE AMOUNT.
OF UP- THE AMOUNT OF THE DEBT.
INCURRED BY THE- NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS WAS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN THAT COULD HAVE BEEN-
PROVIDED TO. PATIENTS WAS A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SO I'M JUST WONDERING
WHAT THE- DOLLAR AMOUNT. WAS
FOR LET'S SAY FOR PROFIT ALSO
HOSPITALS. I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AT MY FINGERTIPS
IT'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION I'M
ASSUMING THAT THEY WERE JUST
STARTING THIS PARTICULAR COHORT
OF HOSPITALS IN THIS PARTICULAR
STUDY- I WILL ASK IF ANY OF
THOSE SPONSORS HAPPEN TO HAVE
THAT DATA AVAILABLE. OR IF WE
EVEN KNOW. AT EMPLOYEE I DON'T
HAVE THE EXACT NUMBERS
AVAILABLE BUT IT THE DATA IS
THERE AND NONPROFIT AND FOR
PROFIT HOSPITALS ARE ACTUALLY
VERY SIMILAR IN- HOW THEY ARE
BOTH PROVIDING CHARITY CARE AND
THE AMOUNT OF CHARITY CARE THAT
THEY'RE LEAVING ON THE TABLE.
YEAH AND THE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WAS THAT
JUST FOR ONE YEAR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT WAS JUST FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN NINETY OKAY AND
JUST FOR THE NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS GOT IT. OKAY THANK.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS IS DAVIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- QUESTION
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THIS BILL LAWS ON. A PENALTY
AGAINST THE HOSPITALS- IF THEY
BUILD THE PATIENT WRONGLY. AND
DOESN'T ALLOW THEM TO APPEAL IS
THAT CORRECT. WELL WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON WHAT THE ACTUAL
PENALTY. PART OF THE SCHOOL
WILL BE THAT'S. WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ABOUT- WE SIR
WANTED TO. MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE A REAL READ TO FOLLOW THE
LAW- YOU KNOW THAT HAVE ENOUGH
OF. TO MAKE THEM THINK TWICE-
AND TO SET UP. A FULL IN THEIR
OWN HOSPITALS COMPLY TO REALLY
SURE THAT THIS AND- IS BEING
PER. TO PAY PATIENTS. OUR GOAL
IS NOT TO BE PUNITIVE IT'S
REALLY TO GET THE HOSPITAL'S
INTO COMPLIANCE. IN AND I
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERN ON
THAT ALSO DO WE HAVE AN IDEA OF
WHAT KIND OF PENALTY WOULD BE
AND- IF SO WHERE DOES THAT
PENALTY GOING HOUSE TO BE USED.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A SLIDING
SCALE SO THE FIRST OFFENSE OF
COURSE WOULD BE MUCH LOWER AND
THEN THE MAXIMUM OFFENSE WORD
WORLD TALKING ABOUT NUMBERS
AROUND THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR MARK. AND I WILL JUST
SAY THAT IT'S HARD TO PUT A
PENALTY NUMBER ON AN ACTION
THAT COULD LITERALLY RUIN
SOMEONE'S LIFE. I WANT A
PATIENT FEELS THAT THEY'D
RATHER BE DEAD. THAN PUT THEIR
FAMILY THROUGH- ECONOMIC RUIN-
IF SOMEONE'S HOUSE IS TAKEN
AWAY IF THEY ARE UNABLE TO GET
A JOB IF THEY CAN'T GET A LOAN
ANYMORE FOR THEIR CHILD-
BECAUSE OF MEDICAL THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T OF ACCRUED IN THE
FIRST PLACE IT'S HARD TO SAY
WHAT THE FAIR NUMBER IS FOR THE
HOSPITAL. BUT THAT'S WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ON AN AD I THINK
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS YOU KNOW
EVERYBODY MAKES MISTAKES- SO
I'D HATE TO SEE YOU KNOW A FINE
COME AGAINST SOMEONE THAT
ACCIDENTALLY MADE A MISTAKE
WHEN THEY WERE BILLING
SOMETHING- AND- YOU KNOW IF
THEY DO ACTUALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAL- TO BE
ABLE TO PROVE THAT YOU KNOW IT
WASN'T. INTENTIONAL I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN AND I
AGREE WITH YOU- SOMETIMES
THINGS SLIP THROUGH THE CRACKS
BUT IF YOU HAVE A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
WHEN YOU'RE JUST IN YOUR
NONPROFIT HOSPITAL SECTOR. THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WAS STILL
CLEARLY THE HOSPITALS NEED TO
SYSTEMICALLY LOOK AT THE
PROCESSES. AND SO. IT'S HOW IT
LOOKS TO ME IS THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT MECHANISMS JUST-IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY SINGLE PATIENT WHO
DESERVES- THIS RELIEF IS
GETTING IT. SO HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL PUSH THEM TO SET UP THOSE
MUCH MORE. ROBUST SORTS OF
PROCEDURES AND MAKE THE IT'S
MUCH MORE ROUTINE. FOR THEM TO
CHECK FOR. THE SAME WITHOUT. IF
YOU HAVE A FEVER IF YOU HAVE AN
INFECTION BEFORE YOU LEAVE THE
HOSPITAL THEY SHOULD BE
CHECKING TO MAKE SURE YOU CAN
PAY YOUR BILLS. AND FORGIVE ME
IF YOU'VE YOU'VE ANSWERED THIS
AGAIN WHERE WOULD THIS- WHERE
WOULD THIS PENALTY GO TO- THAT
I BELIEVE WOULD PROBABLY. YOU
KNOW I'M GONNA HAVE TO DOUBLE
CHECK WHAT'S IN THE TEXT OF THE
BILL BUT I'M ASSUMING IT WOULD
GO TO THE AGENCIES THE WAY THAT
THESE. NORMALLY DUE TO CONTINUE
pTHANK YOU APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU THANKS FOR THE QUESTIONS
STROKE. YEAH THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND I APPRECIATE THE
ISSUE I MEAN I WAS ONE OF THE-
LEGISLATORS WHO STOOD UP TO END
SURPRISE BILLING- YOU KNOW WHEN
THE BILL ACTUALLY FAILED. THE
FIRST TIME- AND SO ON CERTAINLY
NO ONE WHO. I'M CERTAINLY ONE
WHO IS. SPOT ON THIS ISSUE IS
CONCERNED ABOUT. HOSPITAL DEBT
I THINK THER NEEDS TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENCY IN PRICING- WHEN
IT COMES TO HEALTH CARE- BUT
FOR ME ON. ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE I THINK. THERE'S ALREADY
A LOT OF PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
FOR INSTANCE WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY PERCENT. OF
POVERTY LEVEL IS ELIGIBLE FOR
CHARITABLE CARE NOW- AND WE
HAVE- PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO
HELP INSURE THAT. THAT THOSE
THINGS ARE FOLLOWED THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL. IS IT
ADDS A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION-
WHICH WE KNOW WILL AGAIN BE A
TOOL FOR. ATTORNEYS TO SUE
HOSPITALS- TO COST SOME
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS- THERE'S A
LOT ON THIS FRONT. AND MY
CONCERN ESPECIALLY AS FOR RURAL
HOSPITALS- HELLO MY DISTRICT
HAVE BEEN THROUGH HELL- DURING
COVERT NINETEEN- FIRST WITH
THE- INITIAL SURGE IN SHUTTING
DOWN THE HOSPITAL'S TO ELECTIVE
PROCEDURES WHICH NEARLY KILLED-
MANY OF MY RURAL HOSPITALS. AND
I. AND I THINK IT'S STILL AN
OPEN QUESTION AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'LL RECOVER- THEN TO
ADD ADDITIONAL- YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL LIABILITY POTENTIAL
LAWSUITS- YOU KNOW IF THEY
DON'T FOLLOW EVERY IOTA- AND
GIVE THE EXACT. THE EXACT
NOTICES REQUIRED- THE MORE WE
KEEP ADDING THESE KINDS OF
THINGS IN PLACE WHEN THEY'RE-
WHEN AGAIN. THERE ALREADY ARE A
LOT OF PROTECT. PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE FOR CHARITABLE- TERRIBLE
KERR- THERE ARE ALREADY A LOT
OF PROVISIONS IN PLACE TO HELP
TO ENSURE. THAT THERE'S NOT
SURPRISE BILLING AGAIN WE- THIS
LEGISLATURE HELP ENSURE THAT.
THAT HAPPENS- YEAH MUCH- YOU
KNOW. AGAINST MANY AND HOW CARE
STAY. WHO WERE NOT WHO DID NOT
WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN- BUT I
JUST FEEL LIKE IN THIS AREA
THERE'S ALREADY A LOT OF
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE. AND I
DON'T WANT TO PUT AN ADDITIONAL
LIABILITY BURDEN UPON HOSPITALS
THEY'RE ALREADY. HAVING A HARD
TIME MAKING IT THROUGH AS IT IS
AND IF THERE IS NO HOSPITAL.
AND SO MYERS THAT MEANS PEOPLE
DON'T GET CARE THAT'S GOING TO
BE A MUCH GREATER THREAT. TO
THEIR HEALTH CARE- THEN. THEN
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
UP VOTE THANK YOU FOR THE
CONCERNS AND CERTAINLY THERE
VERY VALID CONCERNS AND I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT ALSO THAT THE
IMMENSITY DID PUT AN APPEALS
PROCESS IN. SO THE HOSPITALS DO
HAVE A WAY OF APPEALING SAYING
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS GREAT
SYSTEM IT'S JUST YOU KNOW THE
PAPER GOT JAMMED IN THE PRINTER
WHATEVER IT IS. THEY CAN SHOW
THAT THERE IS A WAY THAT THEY
CAN APPEAL ANY FINE AND AGAIN
THE FINES WOULD START AT A YOU
KNOW WHATEVER LOW LEVEL AND
INCREASE. AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THIS. HAVING PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS ARE NOT PROTECTIONS
IF THE CONSUMERS ARE NOT
NOTIFIED BY THE HOSPITALS THAT
THEY EXIST. IF YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE VULNERABLE WHO ARE
SICK. WHO ARE MAYBE GOING
THROUGH THE WORST WEEK OF THEIR
LIFE WHO ARE AT A POINT WHERE
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO. TO FIND
THE STUFF OUT FOR THEMSELVES OR
TO GO HIRE A LAWYER THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOW INCOME. WHO
ARE CLEARLY AND ARE VERY
VULNERABLE STATE. THE HOSPITALS
HAVE GOT TO TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THOSE
PROTECTIONS IF THEY DON'T DO
THAT THE PROTECTIONS BECOME
IRRELEVANT. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS SAYING
WE HAVE A PROBLEM HERE. WE HAVE
OUR FREE LEGAL AID- OF THE
PROVIDER SAYING WE HAVE A
PROBLEM THESE PEOPLE. THE LUCKY
ONES ARE FINDING THEIR WAY TO
US AND THEN WE CAN HELP THEM
BUT HOW MANY MORE. ARE JUST
GOING BANKRUPT HOW MANY MORE
ARE LOSING EVERYTHING WHEN THE
PROTECTIONS THAT YOU HAD SET UP
IN THAT IN THERE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SET UP IS RIGHT
THERE WAITING FOR THEM. IF THEY
CAN'T ACCESS THAT IF THEY'RE
NOT TOLD ABOUT IT THEY'RE NOT
JUST GOING TO FIND THEIR WAY
THERE. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT IT'S NOT ABOUT BEING
PUNITIVE TO THE HOSPITAL'S IT'S
SAYING. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
REPORT WAS DONE SHOWING THAT
THIS CARE THE PEOPLE WERE OVER
TOOL FOR WAS NOT GIVEN TO THEM.
THEY'VE HAD NOW THREE YEARS TO
FIX THE PROBLEM THEY HAVEN'T
MOVED AND EVEN THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IS SAYING THEY
AGREE THAT THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY AND NOW WE'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO THE
PENALTIES WORK SO THAT THEY'RE
NOT FUGITIVE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM. AND
WE WANT TO MAKE THIS WORKABLE
FOR HOSPITALS WE YOU KNOW WE
WANT TO BE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THEM BUT WE ALSO WANT THEM TO
MAKE THE SYSTEMIC CHANGES THAT
THEY NEED. TO PROTECT OUR
RESIDENTS. AND MY ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER SPECIFIC CONCERNS NO
THERE WAS NOT A QUESTION IN
THAT THERE WAS A STATEMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU AND I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS CAN WE TAKE
THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES YES THANK
YOU RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY SO I'M
STILL LOOKING FOR A MOTION AND
SECOND. SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO HEALTH
COMMITTEE. CALDERON PLACE STONE
HI STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOW CHOW CHOW I TO.
DAVIES NO DAVIS NOW GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES FIVE I
THANK YOU ALL THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHTS RESERVED
THEY ARE SO WE'LL MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FOR AB. FOUR OH NINE.
RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE FOR HEARING AB
FOUR NINE THIS MORNING. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE BILL AND WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. AB FOUR
NINE SIMPLY ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE VICTIMS OF OR WITNESSES
OF GANG CRIMES TO BRING
EVIDENCE OF A THREAT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN ORDER TO HAVE
THEIR NAMES REMOVED FROM PUBLIC
RECORDS. RATHER THAN EXPANDING
THE LIST OF CRIMES THAT
ENTITLES A VICTIM TO HAVE THEIR
NAME WITHHELD. THIS BILL SEEKS
TO EMPOWER VICTIMS TO USE TOOLS
THAT EXIST UNDER CURRENT LAW.
FOR PROTECTING THEIR SAFETY AND
ANONYMITY BY INFORMING THEM OF
THEIR RIGHTS. IN A RECENT
FAMOUS STUDY NEARLY 40% OF
PARTICIPANTS. LISTED FEAR OF
RETALIATION. AS A REASON THEY
WOULD NOT REPORTED CRIME. FOR
INFORMATION THEY KNOW ABOUT A
CRIME. WE KNOW THAT GAIN CRIMES
ARE NOTORIOUS FOR RETALIATES
RETALIATION EFFORTS AND I KNOW
THIS PERSONALLY. AND ARE OFTEN
DIFFICULT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SOLVE. BY OFFERING THE
COMMUNITY THIS SIMPLE
PROTECTION WE CAN HELP FOSTER
COOPERATION BETWEEN ITS MEMBERS
AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT AB
FOUR NINE DOES NOT PLACE ANY
EXTRA BURDENS OR NEW PROCEDURES
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT. ANY
EMPLOYEE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ALREADY REQUIRED TO INFORM
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THEIR NAME WILL BECOME PUBLIC
RECORD UNLESS OTHERWISE
REQUESTED. THIS BILL FOLLOWS
THE SAME PROCEDURE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
WOULD LIKE TO PASS IT OVER TO
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WHO IS A
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF DIDN'T
MAKE YOU CRY I DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS LISTED IN SUPPORT WHO'S
WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE AND
THAT IS RAIN SHERMAN FROM THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION.
BRIAN SHERMAN. MAYBE YOU'RE ON
THE AIR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ASSEMBLY LINE IS OPEN MAYBE YOU
HAVE YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. ONE
MOMENT. WHERE TO CHECK IN A
LINE TO SEE IF HE'S ON OUR
MOMENT OF THE CHAIR THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR ROBERT- ON MY
PROMOTION ARM SORRY WHERE WERE
ON HOLD RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL-
THANK YOU I DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND THERE IS A SECOND. THE
OPERATOR IS STILL WITH HIM. THE
CHAIR SO ONE SECOND.
MARGARET
HEY I HAVE THEM LINED UP I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT HE SUPPORTS
THIS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE MISTER CHAIR THERE
STILL TRYING TO SEE PEOPLE.
OKAY SO IT LOOKS LIKE HE'S NOT
RESPONDING TO US MISTER CHAIR
OKAY ALL RIGHT THEN. WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES WHO WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT TO A BEFORE OR NOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR OH
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR OH
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
AT THIS TIME IS THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. RIGHT THANK
YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION. WITNESS LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ONLINE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE. RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU
JUST UP THE LINE FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION DAY BEFORE- NINE.
THE MESSAGE CARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOUR OH
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE IT BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
OH NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
THEIR OWN NOW. ONE MOMENT SURE
WE DO HAVE ONE PARTY QUEUING UP.
MY NUMBER THIRTY FIVE DEADLINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SICK NOT SHORTHANDED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TERMS
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM I WENT THINK THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE FOR.
PUBLICATION BUT WE HADN'T CAME
IN TODAY CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD ON REALLY WANTED TO
JUST CLARIFY WHY WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL TWENTY FOUR. THREE
REASONS LET ME TELL ON ONE
CHARGE. AND THAT IS THAT PUBLIC
RIGHT ACT REQUEST- JERRY RARELY
USE IN THE TWO SITUATION. THAT
ARE DESCRIBED BY THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL. WELL OUR PRIMARY CAN.
TAGS THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
LARGEST TO. AND TO- INVESTIGATE
A POLICE. ABUSE. ENTER ISSUE
CLICK DISCOUNT OF IN THAT IS
**** TO RECORD TO THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT. AND WE ARE NOW
WITH THE TROUT THE BILL YOU
WILL. AN OFFICER CAN ALLOW.
THAT SOMEONE IS DELETED WITH A
GANG AND WE KNOW THERE ARE A
LOT OF PROBLEM. IN A LOT OF
MISSION MADE. I SOME SERVERS I
LIKE COMMITTED IN A OF THE GANG
AND BY. SO THEY COULD TRY. THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL NAME FROM WE BE.
ANY PUBLIC ACT REQUEST. UNLIKE
THE OTHER BILLS W. ONE OF THE
VIOLENCE- BEING A MEMBER OF THE
GANG SOMETHING IS. NOT A J. AND
HAVE BEEN PROVED TO BE MANY
TIMES BY LAW FOR. AND THEN DOES
COULD. SIGNIFICAN LIMIT THE
ABILITY TO COOLEY. SO GOT THE
PRIMARY YOU WHY WORK BY WE CAN
GET. MANY IN LAW REALLY TO- BUT
SEXUAL ABUSE K. YEAH IT WILL
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WAY TO THE
LATEST THAT- BECAUSE IT JUST
LAW HOW YOU KNOW HOW LONG.
ALLEGES GANG- THE LONGEST MANY.
NOT A LOT I'LL MENTION TO BUY A
CONTRACT AND IS THAT- WELL OR
ALSO TO TURN THAT- IT DIDN'T.
AND WITNESSES CAN ALREADY THAT
THEY ARE. THAT THEY CAREFULLY
THAT COULD TRIGGER SOMETHING
CHECK FROM SO THIS ONLY A IN
THE BECAUSE WILL DETERMINE WHAT
GOT NOT RATE THE IN. ONE I'M
SAKE OR TRY AND SO WE'RE
CONCERNED. ALONG COUNTY HEY
KEEP YOUR NAME OUT OF THE
PUBLIC. IF YOU SAY THAT YOU'RE
BILL AND THAT'S CAN THAT THEY
WERE ONLY THEMSELVES- I HAPPEN
TRY TO TAKE OUT A RESOLUTION
AND COULD CONVERSE WITHOUT
OFFICE. ON THE WE DO THINK THAT
PEOPLE SERIOUS WHEN I TRY. THAT
EXIST OUTSIDE OF THE LOCAL IS
OF THIS BECAUSE OF THE WAY
BILLS. I COULDN'T A LOT OF.
THANK YOU FOR OTHER. ONE THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING FOR THIS BILL
GREAT MEASURE AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING TODAY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS. RIGHT
SYNONYMOUS WITH THIRTY MAKE
OVER. THAT'S RIGHT YOU AND I
JUST GOT BACK THIS SERVICE WELL
THAT'S RIGHT. THANK YOU I THINK
THAT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PROTECTIONS FOR WITNESSES- IT
CLEARLY IS OF GREAT IMPORTANCE-
IF SOMEBODY COMES FORWARD
SEEKING JUSTICE WE DO HAVE TO
PROVIDE JUSTICE AND PROTECTION
FOR THEM AS WELL. MY ONLY
CONCERN WAS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS IS SOME DUPLICATION
AND I HOPE THAT AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD THAT WHATEVER
DUPLICATION THERE IS THAT THAT
WILL BE ADDRESSED BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY BY.
CLICKING THANK YOU. RIGHT YOU
MAY CLOSE. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- FOR HEARING THE
BILL TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHOLERA
PLEASE STONE. HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHIU. DAVIS HIGH DAVIS
HI GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KALRA. KILEY AYE KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN REYES RESIDE. THE
BILL IS APT THANK YOU THANK YOU
HI THERE BRINGS US TO AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE MS WICKS.
DO YOU. SHE HASN'T SHOWN UP YET.
THANK YOU TURN COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING SO DILIGENTLY
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL I GLADLY
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS IN RECENT YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATORS
TAKING BOLD STEPS TO IMPROVE
AND PROVIDE PATHWAYS TO JUSTICE
FOR SURVIVORS SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL SEXUAL ASSAULT. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE UNANIMOUSLY
PASSED AB SIXTEEN NINETY
NINETEEN WHICH EXTENDS THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
ADULT VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
FROM TWO YEARS. TO TEN YEARS
AFTER THE ASSAULT OR THREE
YEARS AFTER DISCOVERING. IN
TWENTY TWENTY THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THIRTY NINETY TWO
WHICH EXTENDED THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR SURVIVORS TO
SEEK JUSTICE AGAINST A
SPECIFIED ABUSER. WHO IS AN
OBGYN AT UCLA- WHO COMMITTED
SEXUAL ASSAULT AGAINST MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED WOMEN. BECAUSE
THE STATE DOES NOT CURRENTLY
INSURE SAFETY MEASURES FOR
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DESPITE DOCUMENTED INCIDENCES
OF OFFICERS USING THEIR POWER
AND AUTHORITY TO STOCK ARREST
THREATEN TO RETALIATE AGAINST
THEIR VICTIMS. ADDITIONAL
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION IS
URGENTLY NEEDED. AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY FIVE EXTENDS THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS FOR VICTIMS WHO
WERE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED BY A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER TO TEN
YEARS AFTER THE ALLEGED
PERPETRATOR. WAS EMPLOYED AS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER OR
WITHIN TEN YEARS FROM THE DATE
OF JUDGMENT IN A CRIMINAL CASE
WHICHEVER IS LATER TO ALLOW
SURVIVORS TO FILE A CIVIL
CLAIM. TAKE THE CASE OF NO
WHITE WINCHESTER WHO SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED A TOTAL OF FIVE WOMEN
INVOLVED IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHILE SERVING AS ACTIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. NONE OF WOULD
TESTERS VICTIMS SUED HIM NOR
THE DEPARTMENT THAT EMPLOYED
HIM WITHIN THE TIME FRAME
ALLOWED. UNDER CURRENT LAW
BECAUSE THEY VIEWED THAT THEIR
LIFE WOULD BE AT RISK OF
LIBERTY. ADDITIONALLY AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE WILL
OTHERWISE TIME BARRED CIVIL
CASES TO MOVE FORWARD. MEMBERS
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS NOT
TO CAST JUDGEMENT OR SHAME ON
LOST LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
AND I KNOW MANY OF WHOM. ARE
GOOD UPSTANDING PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING THEIR JOBS AND DOING THEM
THE RIGHT WAY. BUT THIS BILL
SIMPLY KNOWLEDGES THAT-
INTIMIDATION AND BARRIERS TO
REPORTING. THE VICTIM'S FACE
WHEN THEY KNOW THEIR ATTACKER
HAS THE ABILITY TO PUNISH
ARREST OR RETALIATE AGAINST
THEM. FROM A POSITION OF POWER.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW VICTIMS MORE TIME TO
SAFELY COME FORWARD IF THEIR
ABUSER HAS THE POWER TO THIRTY
TO TAKE AWAY THEIR FREEDOM. AND
LIBERTIES FOR SIMPLY TELLING
THEIR STORY IN SEEKING JUSTICE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY ARE
SHERRY CARTER IN AT HOWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE. THREE
SUPPORT WITNESSES LISTED SHERRY
CARTER AN INDIVIDUAL AT HOWARD
AN INDIVIDUAL AND THEN. TIED
EMMANUEL WHO IS ON THE LINE
STANDING BY FOR QUESTIONS. AND
SO MISS CARTER. HI MY NAME IS
SHERRY CARTER AND I'M SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE. I'M UNITED STATES NAVY
VETERAN WHO WORE MY UNIFORM
WITH PRIDE. I LIVED UP TO MY
PROMISE TO SUPPORT AND DEFEND
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
MY UPBRINGING IN MILITARY
TRAINING TAUGHT ME TO TRUST AND
RESPECT OF THE ALREADY. WHEN I
WAS REPEATEDLY RAPED BY AN ON
DUTY UNIFORMED OFFICER. THAT
TROUBLES RUINED. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN I ENCOUNTERED
I ENCOUNTER OFFICER NO OF
WINCHESTER OF THE SAM HILL
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND HE FOUND
ME AT MY WORST AND HE KNEW IT.
PREDATORS LIKE HIM YOU SEE A
STORY OF THEIR BADGES TO HUNT
WOMEN LIKE ME. I WAS VULNERABLE.
HOMER ALONE AND I WAS LOSING MY
BATTLE WITH ADDICTION. THE
OFFICER WAS ON THE CLOCK RIGHT
BY HIS CONTROL VEHICLE WITH HIS
BAD HIS GUN AND A FLASHLIGHT HE
USED TO INSPECT MY BODY. AND HE
THREATENED TO ARREST ME BEFORE
MAKING ME FALL INTO. A DARK
AREA WHERE HE RAPED ME OVER AND
OVER. WHAT CAN I DO CALL THE
POLICE ON THE POLICE.
APPARENTLY. I KNEW THEY MIGHT
NEVER. I KNEW THEY MIGHT NEVER
BELIEVE MIGHT NEVER BELIEVE ME
BUT I COOPERATED FULLY WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM I TOLD
THE TRUTH. AND OTHER VICTIMS
HAVE THE SAME CHANCE THAT I DID.
DURING THE CRIMINAL CASE I
ANSWERED THE CALL EVERY TIME I
NEEDED TO BE READY TO TESTIFY
OR NEEDED TO BE PATIENT WITH
MORE DELAYS OR NEEDED TO TELL
THE JURY WILL. HAVE MY NAME
HERE IN FRONT OF THE ATTACKER.
AS HIS LAWYER TRIED TO MAKE ME
LOOK LIKE A LIAR. CALIFORNIA
DOES AGAINST MY ATTACKER WITH
THE HELP OF HELP IN SACRIFICE
TO MYSELF AND OTHER VICTIMS BUT-
WHERE ARE WE AFTER ALL THIS.
BECAUSE OF THE SHORT LEGAL
DEADLINE RIGHT NOW THERE IS NO
CIVIL JUSTICE FOR US. WE HAVE
NO RIGHT TO SEEK COMPENSATION
TO REMAIN HOME. SO WE CAN GET
THERAPY NEEDED TO TRULY AND
COMPLETELY DEAL WITH PTSD. TE
DOORS OF THE COURTHOUSE AND NOT
BE SLAMMED HONEST WE DESERVE A
CHANCE TO EMPOWER OURSELVES
AGAIN BY SEEKING CIVIL JUSTICE.
AGAINST THOSE RESPONSIBLE AND I
HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE. FOR ME AND
FOR THE OTHER VICTIM. THANK YOU
MISTER HOWARD. THE RIVER AT
HOWARD. THE ALLIED CARE HATE HE
IS NOT ON THE PHONE. OKAY IS
THERE ANOTHER WITNESS MR
EMMANUEL YOU ARE HERE FOR.
QUESTIONS WHERE DO YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY THERE ARE NO FURTHER
WITNESSES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOWARD DOES AND TO SPEAK BUT-
RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
COULD OPEN THE LINES THEN FOR.
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
LINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO. YEAH
WOULD GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL. THE MESSAGE CARE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUILT THEIR OWN NOW.
AT THIS TIME MEDICARE WE HAVE
TO PARTICIPATE WE HAVE THREE
PARTICIPANT IN Q. THANK YOU.
FINAL THANK YOU MR LINE NUMBER
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS REBECCA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT
HERE WE'RE STILL GATHERING
NUMBERS. LINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS DANIELLE AND
I AM A SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVOR
AND VICTIM OF OFFICE IN
WINCHESTER I SUPPORT IN THE.
ONE FOUR FIVE FIVE. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
FIFTEEN ATTACK ARE WITH THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND DRUNK A COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT THE
TIME OF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE CAN KILL. THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE NO OPPOSITION
LISTED. ON THE FILE. SO AFRAID
YOU CAN OPEN THE LINES IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU%
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN THERE- NOW. AND
AT THIS TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. I THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THROUGHOUT YES I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WORK ON ON THIS ISSUE-
AND AS WE TALKED ABOUT I MEAN I
THINK IT'S IT REALLY IS TIME
THAT WE START EXPANDING THIS
INTO THE GOVERNMENT ROUND- NOW
SEE HERE BUT I THINK WE EVEN
OTHER GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
WHERE WHEN YOU'RE IN A PLACE OF
AUTHORITY- THERE MAY NOT BE
THAT SAME IN CENTER BRING
THINGS FORWARD I WAS GOING TO
BRING A JUST A QUESTION OF YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW THE ALLIES TEN
YEARS AFTER THE INCIDENT OR
THREE YEARS FROM LIKE
DISCOVERY- OF THE INJURY- WHAT
WHY NOT I MEAN SINCE IT'S GOING
TO BE SINCE THAT PERSONS OUT
OF. THE PLACE WITH THE ALREADY
WHY NOT DO IT THREE YEARS FROM
THAT DATE AS OPPOSED TO TEN
WHAT'S KIND OF THE REASON FOR
THAT I THINK THE IDEA WOULD BE
WE WOULD WANT TO DO IT- AFTER
THE PERSON'S HONORED PLAY BY
THE AGENCY AND GIVE VICTIMS
MORE TIME BECAUSE IF YOU ARE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL WHO
HAS COMMITTED THESE ACTS AND-
YOU HAVE THERE'S A PART POWER
DYNAMIC THERE RIGHT- AND- THE
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. I
NOT FEEL LIKE THEY CAN BRING A
CASE AGAINST A CURRENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL. AS NOTED
BY THE TESTIMONY OF. OF THE
WINTER SO THIS GIVES THEM MORE
TIME ONCE THAT PERSON IS NO
LONGER EMPLOYED BY THAT AGENCY.
RATHER OF HIS- CONSISTENCY ARE
WE DOING TEN ON OTHER ANOTHER-
INSTANCES AS WELL AS IBM SYSTEM
WITH WHAT WE'VE DONE ANOTHER
YEAH- SOME MEMBER BERMAN SPILL
AND- TWENTY EIGHTEEN- ALLOWED
FOR A- TEN YEARS AFTER THEY'VE
SOLD FOR THREE YEARS AFTER
DISCOVERING. THREE YEARS AFTER
SALAS HIS BILL THAT CREATED
THAT COULD WHAT THE CROWN I
DON'T KNOW IF HIS BILL CREATED
IT BUT I KNOW THAT THAT WAS A-
THAT'S A BILL THAT. CURRENTLY
HAS AN. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SIGNAL
YOU MAY CLOSE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
DON'T. THANK YOU I AM LOOKING
FOR A MOTION. WE DO A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. AT TWO APPROPRIATIONS
I'M SORRY- HELLO TO YES DEFENSE
IS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU STONE HI STONE HI
GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER AYE CHAU
CHOW I CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES ACT
AND SALAS CONSULTS AYE HOLDEN.
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN YES HI RES I. THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE CHAIR OF THE THREE OF US
CAUCUS MISERY THAT'S OUR ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TEN NINETY SIX.
THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS- I WANT TO
START BY THANKING MERRY FOR HER
WORK ON THIS ANALYSIS- AB TEN
NINETY SIX IS A LATINO CAUCUS
PRIORITY. THIS BILL DELETE
OUTDATED AND OFFENSIVE TERMS.
SUCH AS ALIEN WHICH IS FOUND.
OPERATOR THANK YOU. YOU ARE
RIGHT OKAY I'LL CONTINUE AND
ARE YOU ASKING THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE YOU KNOW YES I AM
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS- I WELL
YOU KNOW IT SO ALSO GO AHEAD
AND RESTATE WHAT THIS BILL
DOES- IT OUT IT. THE BILL
DELETE OUTDATED AND OFFENSIVE
TERMS SUCH AS A LAN WHICH IS
FOUND THROUGHOUT OUR STATE LAWS
AND REPLACES IT WITH
APPROPRIATE LEGAL TERM AND
KNOWLEDGE HE SUGGESTS-
SEEM SIMPLE IT HAS SIGNIFICANT
IMPLICATIONS ALTHOUGH THE TERM
ALIEN HAS HISTORICALLY REFERRED
TO INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NON
CITIZENS THE WORD HAS SINCE
BEEN WEAPONIZED AND USED IN-PLACE OF AN EXPLICITLY RACIAL
SLUR- THERE'S A DIRECT LINK
BETWEEN WORDS AND ACTIONS. AND
HISTORY HAS PROVEN THAT
DEHUMANIZING LANGUAGE OFTEN
PROCEEDS FILE ACTIONS AB TEN
NINETY SIX INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS- CONSIST OF
TERMINOLOGY THAT ALIGN WITH OUR
IDEALS- TODAY UP TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I HAVE
BETH HOLTZMAN. WITH THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE ONE WITNESS LISTED IN
THAT IS BETHEL'S MINUTE THE
ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE. SO IT'S
BEEN ARE YOU ON THE LINE. YES I
AM GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS. DAN
AND I SERVE AS THE WESTERN
STATE CIVIL RIGHTS COUNCIL FOR
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND
REPRESENTS EIGHTY L. FIVE
CALIFORNIA OFFICES. I'M HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN NINETY SIX WHICH WERE
NEW THE OFFENSIVE TERM ALIEN
FROM CALIFORNIA STATUTES WHEN
REFERRING TO INDIVIDUALS. WHO
ARE NOT U. S. CITIZENS AND
REPLACE IT WITH MORE INCLUSIVE
TERMS. FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
THIRTEEN IN RESPONSE TO AN
ESCALATING CLIMATE OF ANTI
SEMITISM AND BIGOTRY ADL HAVE
NOW BECOME A LEADING ANTI
ORGANIZATION. AS WE STRIVE TO
THE BILL OUR FOUNDING MISSION
TO SECURE JUSTICE AND FAIR
TREATMENT TO ALL OUR GOAL IS A
WORLD IN WHICH NO GROUP OR
INDIVIDUAL SUFFERS FROM BIAS
DISCRIMINATION OR HATE. ADL HAS
ADVOCATED FOR FAIR AND HUMANE
IMMIGRATION POLICY SINCE OUR
FOUNDING AND I'VE BEEN THE
LEADER IN EXPOSING ANTI
IMMIGRANT AND ANTI REFUGEE
HATE. THAT APPOINTMENT OUR
NATION DEBATE. EMPLOYING THE
OUTDATED TERM ALIEN TO DESCRIBE
A PERSON IS DEHUMANIZING
ALTHOUGH IT IS NOT EXPLICIT
RACIAL SLUR IS BECOME A CODE
WORD FOR BIGOTRY AGAINST
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES. LANGUAGE
SHAPE ATTITUDES USING TERMS
LIKE ALIEN TO REFER TO A PERSON
CAN LEAD TO PREJUDICE AND EVEN
HARMFUL ACTION. AB TEN NINETY
SIX PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THE NARRATIVE AROUND
IMMIGRATION BY REMOVING THE
TERM ALIEN FROM CALIFORNIA
STATUTE AND REPLACING IT WITH
MORE INCLUSIVE LEGAL TERMS. FOR
THESE REASONS ADL SUPPORT
PASSAGE OF PEPSI CAN ID. SIX
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU APPLY FOR ANYWAY
WHO WOULD LIKE SPEAK AND- OF.
AB TEN NINETY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN NINETY
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN NINETY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN THERE-
NOW. WE HAVE THREE
PARTICIPATING Q. MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISS GROUPS- PHONE NUMBER SUCK
BROWN BOTH SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
BY NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
NUTCRACKER AT THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. AND AT THE TIME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU. MOVED OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED SO
OPERATOR COULD YOU APPLIANCE
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF. TEN
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TEN NINETY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR ONLINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TEN NINETY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE- NOW. AND
WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON TO
ANOTHER THE CHAIR ONE MOMENT.
LINE NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
H. GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS THIS IS RON RAPP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND I
MISSED THE CUTEST SUPPORT AB
TEN NINETY SIX THE I AM
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATORS ANYONE
ELSE ALIGNED WITH IT IS SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. NO MEDICARE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE COULD HEAL
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ARE FOR YOU
CAN CLOSE THE LINES OVER YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS IS GONZALEZ. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL AND- I THINK LIKE SO
MANY CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS-
YOU KNOW WE LIVED OUR LIVES
BEING TAUNTED WITH WITH TERMS
THAT EVEN IN SCHOOL- TEACHERS
WOULD OFTEN SAY IS A-
ACCEPTABLE TERM IT'S A LEGAL
TERM WE USE THAT TO WRITE BUT
THE AMOUNT OF DEHUMANISATION
THAT WAS PUT BEHIND THIS TERM
IN USED IN WEAPONIZED AGAINST
US AS CHILDREN. IS SOMETHING I
THINK SO MANY OF US LIVE WITH
SO I WOULD HAVE NEVER THOUGHT-
THAT YOU CAN ADD DE LEGITIMIZE
THE TERM BY TAKING IT OUT OF
THE CODE AND IT'S BRILLIANT AND
I HOPE THAT- THAT NO E. ON THE
IMMIGRANTS OLDER IMMIGRANTS
NOEL CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS
EVER HAVE TO DEAL WITH. I THINK
THE PURE HATRED THAT SO MANY OF
US FELT- GROWING UP WITH WITH
THE UTILIZATION OF THIS TERM SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THINKING OF THIS AND THANK YOU
FOR DOING THIS IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT- NOT SYMBOLIC BUT A
VERY IMPORTANT ACT. IN ORDER
TO- REMOVE IT FROM A LEGITIMATE
TERM THAT'S USED. THANK YOU
VISITORS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH-
SOMEONE MEMBER RIVAS FOR
BRINGING THIS. I AGREE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ. THE
WORDS WE USE MATTER TELLS US
WHO AND WHAT WE VALUE. AND WHEN
WE USE A WORD LIKE ALIEN IT'S
CLEARLY USED TO SLANDER OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND TO
NOT DENY THEIR HUMANITY. YOU'RE
RIGHT AS DAUGHTER'S DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANTS- WE HEAR THIS WHERE
THERE ARE PARENTS ARE ARE ARE
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED
YOU'RE AN IMMIGRANT AND IF THE
WORD IS USED. SIMPLY TO DE
HUMANIZE. OF MANY OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY KNOW THAT WHEN PEOPLE
REFER TO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
MEMBERS AS ALIENS. THEY'RE
DOING SO BECAUSE I'LL BE LEGAL
THEY'RE NOT DOING IT BECAUSE OF
A LEGAL PREFERENCE THEY'RE
DOING IT AS WAS SAID TO SLANDER
AND TO HUMANIZE HUMANIZE AND TO
REMIND TO SOMEBODY THAT THEY
DON'T BELONG- IT'S ESPECIALLY
TELLING US SINCE WE HAVEALTERNATIVE LANGUAGE THAT WE
CAN USE AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR.
MAKING SURE THAT OUR CODE OUR
LAWS- REFLECTING THE
ALTERNATIVE LANGUAGE THAT CAN
BE USED- I THINK REMOVED
REMOVING IT FROM OUR FROM OUR
LEXICON AND OUR OUR OUR LAWS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND HAVING
YOU INTRODUCED THIS ALL RIGHT
AGAIN I- I APPLAUD YOU FOR THIS
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO BE- IF YOU
PERMITTED I'D LOVE TO BE
INCLUDED AS A CO AUTHOR. OF
YOUR BILL. SURE OF COURSE I'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU ON THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON. THROUGH
US YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUPPORT AND- YOU KNOW WHAT I
REMEMBER WHEN. MY MOM BECAME A
PERMANENT RESIDENT OF LEGAL
PERMANENT RESIDENT IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND STILL BEING CALLED
AN ALIEN IT MADE ME FEEL- IT
WAS BEING USED TOWARDS HER LIKE
IF SHE DOESN'T BELONG HERE YET
SHE'S A LEGAL RESIDENT. OF THE
UNITED STATES SO THAT'S WHY FOR
ME THIS IS PERSONAL- AND THAT'S
WHY. I DECIDED TO DO THIS I
THINK I AGREE WITH ALL OF YOU
THAT WORDS MATTER. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
LOOKING FOR A MOTION. BUT THANK
YOU POSTED BY MR CHILD
SACRAMENTO'S RIVAS AND THAT
MOTIONS TO PASS. GRAYSON
AUTHORED WITH IT IS A FEELING-
SOME. RIGHT TO THE END THAT
MOTIONSTO PASS AS AMENDED CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE
HI GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I CHAO
CHAO AYE CHIU DAVIES AYE DAVIES
AYE GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
REYES FIVE THREE AS I. THE
BILLS UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT MR KILEY. LITTLE MOVE
ASIDE OF NUMBER SIX AB TWO
SEVENTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING AB
TWO SEVENTY TWO- WILL ENSURE
THAT A VICTIM OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT CAN PURSUE A
CIVIL ACTION AGAINST THE
PERPETRATOR AND OTHER RELEVANT
PARTIES AT THE NEED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION IS DEMONSTRATED BY
A RECENT CASE- IN THE LA AREA
WHERE A STUDENT WAS SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
BY HIS CHEMISTRY TEACHER. WHILE
THE TEACHER WAS CRIMINALLY
PROSECUTED AND DID SERVE JAIL
TIME THE VICTIM'S CIVIL CLAIM
WAS FORCED INTO ARBITRATION BY
THE SCHOOL AS IT TURNED OUT-
THE VICTIM'S PARENTS UPON AND
ROLLING HIM I HAD ENTERED AN-
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT THAT
INCLUDED AN ARBITRATION CLAUSE.
NOW THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY-
PARTIES IN ANY CASE WOULD SEE
ARBITRATION AS A GOOD OPTION TO
AGREED TO UP FRONT FOR
RESOLVING CLAIMS THAT CAN BE-
LESS EXPENSIVE FASTER AND MORE
PRIVATE- HOWEVER THIS IS
PREDICATED. ON THE MUTUAL
AGREEMENT OF THE PARTIES- IN
ADVANCE AND I BELIEVE IT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE- TO FORCE THE
VICTIM OF A CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT IN ARBITRATION AGAINST
THEIR WILL. NOW WHENEVER WERE
DEALING WITH THE TOPIC OF
ARBITRATION OF COURSE THE
FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT IS AN
OVERRIDING CONCERN OF PLACES-
VERY FAR REACHING LIMITS ON THE
ABILITY OF STATES- TO REGULATE
THE ISSUE. HOWEVER I BELIEVE-
THAT- THERE ARE SEVERAL FACTORS
HERE- THAT BRING THIS
LEGISLATION OUTSIDE OF THE
EMBED OF F. A PREVENTION- FIRST
IS- THE UNIQUE ROLE OF
EDUCATION AS BOTH A RIGHT AND-
AND SOMETHING THAT IS
COMPULSORY YOU KNOW I'M LIKE
CONTRACTS FOR SERVICES OR-
OTHER BUSINESS VENTURES A
STUDENT HAD DOESN'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO OPT OUT. OF THEIR
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA OF ALL
REQUIRES MINORS- TO RECEIVEAN
EDUCATION- OF SOME KIND
SECONDLY IT CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS NOT A FORESEEABLE
ALL CIRCUMSTANCE. WHEN
ENROLLING IN SCHOOL. WHEN
PARENTS SIGN THEIR CHILD UP THE
AGREED TO YOU KNOW NUMBER OF
TERMS AND CONDITIONS SCHOOL
HOURS TUITIONS DRESS CODES. AND
SO FORTH BUT IT'S-
UNFORESEEABLE AT THAT TIME THAT
A PARENT WOULD I UNDERSTAND
EIGHT CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT-
TO BE WITHIN THE SCOPE. OF THE
RISKS AT THE TIME OF ENTERING
THE CONTRACT. THAT THIS BILL AB
TWO SEVENTY TWO CLARIFIES AT
THE FORCING A VICTIM OF CHILD
SEXUAL ASSAULT INTO
ARBITRATION- IS UNCONSCIONABLE
AND UNCONSCIONABLE EDDIE-
REMAINS. A GENERAL CONTRACT
OFFENSE- EVEN UNDER- THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT'S LEADING CASE ON
THE FEDERAL ARBITRATION ACT AT
CONCEPCION- FINALLY- CALIFORNIA
LAW IS CLEAR ON THE DIFFERENCE
THAT IS- AFFORDED TO MINORS IN
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES YOUR
PERSONAL CASE LAW SUPPORTS.
THAT CLAIMS HELD BY CHILDREN
CANNOT BE FORCED AND
ARBITRATION AND CHILDREN HAVE
THE RIGHT TO DETERMINE AL
MATTERS THAT CONCERN THEIR
WELFARE ADDITIONALLY FAMILY
CODE SECTION SIXTY SEVEN TEN
PROVIDE THE CONTRACT. OF A
MINOR MAYBE JUST A FIRM AND- BY
THE MINOR. THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT ITSELF DOES NOT
SPEAK TO THE ISSUE OF A
PARENT'S ABILITY TO
CONTRACTUALLY BIND I'M MINOR
AND TO THEREBY FORCED THEM TO
ENTER INTO ARBITRATION TO
RESOLVE A CLAIM THOUGHTS. THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT WE- CAN ACT ON
AT THE STATE LEVEL NOW FOR
FUTURE VICTIMS IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE I TAKE
ACTION ON THIS ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MY FIRST WITNESS- WITH ME
TODAY IS OUR ON THE LINE IS
RICHARD SCHWARTZ. THANK YOU I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES LISTED
MISTER SCHWARTZ WHO IS AN
ATTORNEY AT BROWN GEORGE
RUSSELL BRAND ELLIS AND.
REBECCA SCHWARTZ AN INDIVIDUAL.
ARE EITHER OF YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AND-
COLLECTION RICHARD SHORT THERE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY IN PARTICULAR MY
NAME IS RICHARD SCHWARTZ A
PARTNER AT BROWNE GEORGE ROSS
O'BRIEN AND IGWE IN ALICE AND I
URGE YOU ALL TO SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVENTY TWO. EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY
TWO WOULD ALLOW INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE THE VICTIMS OF CRIMINAL
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR SEXUAL%
BATTERY IN A SCHOOL CONTACTED
EACH OTHER THROUGH THE COURT
SYSTEM EVEN IF THE SCHOOLS
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT WOULD
OTHERWISE SPEND THAT STUDENTS
ARBITRATION. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA LAW AUTHORIZES
SCHOOLS TO FOR STUDENTS AND
PARENTS TO SIGN NON NEGOTIABLE
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT. EGGMAN
SOB AND HAVE QUALITY. AMONG
OTHER THINGS. ALLOW THE SCHOOLS
TO HIDE ITS DISPUTE BEHIND THE
VEIL OF A CONFIDENTIAL
ARBITRATION. EVEN WHEN A
STUDENT HAS CLAIMS BASED ON
PROVEN FACT CRIMINAL SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT. RECEIVE THE CALL
CAN REQUIRED THROUGH FORCED
ARBITRATION IS ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC FOR SCHOOL
COMMUNITY. WHO DESPERATELY NEED
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
PROCEDURE THEIR SCHOOLS ARE
TAKING OR FAILING TO TAKE TO
PREVENT CRIMINAL SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT ON THEIR PREMISES.
EVEN MORE PROBLEMATIC IS THE
IMPACT OF ARBITRATION ON A
VICTIM OF CRIMINAL SEXUAL
ASSAULT. CALIFORNIA LAW MAKES
IT CLEAR THAT AN ARBITRATOR CAN
DECIDE A MATTER BEFORE THAT NOT
ON THE BASIS OF THE LAW OR THE
RULES OF EVIDENCE. BUT RATHER
SOLELY ON AMBIGUOUS NOTIONS OF
EQUITY AS PERCEIVED BY THAT
ARBITRATOR OFTEN A SINGLE
PERSON WITH HIS OR HER OWN
BIASES AND PRECONCEPTIONS. THAT
MEANS THAT AN ARBITRATOR CAN
BLATANTLY IGNORE THE LAW AND
PREVENT THE STUDENT WHO WAS
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED FROM
OBTAINING THE JUSTICE THEY
COULD OBTAIN THROUGH THE
COURTS. AB TWO SEVENTY TWO
EXPECT THAT PROBLEM BY ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO DIFFER FROM THOSE
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT AFTER
BEING THE VICTIM OF A SEXUAL
ASSAULT. I SHOULD EMPHASIZE
THAT AB TWO SEVENTY TWO HAS A
VERY NARROW SCOPE IT'S
PROVISIONS ARE ONLY TRIGGERED
WHEN THERE IS A WHEN THERE'S
CRIMINAL SEXUAL MISCONDUCT THAT
FORMED THE BASIS OF THE STUDENT
QUITE. CALIFORNIA CAN FIX THIS
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWED COUNT
THAT ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO EDUCATE
THE COURT THAT THEM AND AVOID
THE PUBLIC RECONCILIATION
PROCESS THAT WOULD BE
COMMUNITIES NEED TO HEAL ND
MOVE ON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION IN THIS
IMPORTANT BELT WHICH WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TO SECURING JUSTICE
FOR THE VICTIMS OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT. I ASK YOU TO
THE NUMBERS. TO VOTE I IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU. N. AS
REBEKAH SHORT ONLINE. YES I AM
THANK YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING IT IS AN HONOR TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR HEARING THE
VICTIM'S PERSPECTIVE. I COME
FORWARD WE CHOOSE TO STAND UP
FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITY. TO LOWER THE RISK OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN BEING
EXPOSED TO SEXUAL PREDATORS IN
OUR SCHOOL. THIS HAS NOT BEEN A
PATH OF LEAST RESISTANCE. AMONG
THE MANY UGLY TRUTH WE HAVE
LEARNED ON THIS JOURNEY THAT
MANY WOULD PREFER THIS ISSUE
NEVER SEE THE LIGHT OF DAY.
THERE ARE FEW THINGS WORSE THAN
HARMING A CHILD ONE THING I
KNOW WITH WORK IS PREVENTING
THAT CHARLTON SEEKING JUSTICE
FOR THAT HARM. IGNORING THAT IT
EVER HAPPENED. FOUR YEARS AGO
ARCHIBALD WAS REPEATEDLY AND
BRUTALLY RAPED BY A TEACHER AT
BRENTWOOD SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES
NEARLY EVERY DAY FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS BOTH ON AND OFF CAMPUS.
THE PERPETRATOR WAS CRIMINALLY
CONVICTED AND SERVED TIME. ARTS
WORLD ISN'T PERMANENTLY CHANGED
DAMAGES GUARD BY THIS YEAR
BECAUSE I THOUGHT. THE ANGUISH
PAIN AND MISERY COUPLED WITH
THE LOSS OF INNOCENT HAVE BEEN
AND CONTINUE TO BE CHALLENGING.
HEIGHTENED BY THE FACT THAT OUR
CHILD NEVER GOT THE PROVERBIAL
DAY IN COURT. A JURY TRIAL
WOULD HAVE BEEN ONE WAY TO
BRING ABOUT A FULL
INVESTIGATION OF THE CRIME AND
THE SCHOOL POLICIES PROCEDURES
GUIDELINES GOVERNANCE AND
CULTURE WHICH MAY HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CRIME. AND
IN DOING SO WOULD FACILITATE
THE HEALING PROCESS FOR OUR
CHILD. INSTEAD THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SYSTEM DENIED OUR TRIAL
THE JURY TRIAL BECAUSE BRENT
WOODS SCHOOL INCLUDED A
MANDATORY CONFIDENTIAL
ARBITRATION CLAUSE IN ITS
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT. OUR CHILD
TO NOT SIGN A MANDATORY
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS IN YET WOULD HELP TO
IT. MY HUSBAND AND I SIGNED
THAT AGREEMENT BELIEVING THAT
IT MOST ARBITRATION WOULD COVER
GRIEVANCES WE MIGHT HAVE WITH
THE SCHOOL REGARDING OUR
CHILD'S EDUCATION. WE NEVER
ENVISIONED IT WOULD COVER A
FELONY CRIME A VIOLENT ONE AT
THAT. AND WE CERTAINLY NEVER
ENVISIONED THAT WE WERE SIGNING
AWAY OUR CHILD RIGHT TO CHOOSE
THEIR OWN PATH TO JUSTICE. NO.
PARENT DOES OR SHOULD. THE
COMMONSENSE PARENTS JUST EITHER.
IF AT ALL. IS INTO TO REDUCE
THIS RELATED TO ATTEND A SCHOOL
I CAN CRIMINAL A GREAT ART ON.
ARBITRATIONS HAD PLACE A CIVIL
JEFF SYSTEM BUT A WICKS VICTIM
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
ARBITRATION OR COURT. FINALLY
ARBITRATION CLAUSE TO AN
EDUCATOR SEXUAL ABUSE OF A
CHILD AT THE POTENTIAL TO
UNDERMINE ANY CHANCE A TRUE
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. ARBITRATION
THAT IS FORCING CONFIDENTIAL
AND UPROARIOUSLY LIMITS
DISCOVERY AND DISCLOSURE IS NOT
ONLY BAD FOR THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIMS BUT ALSO FOR SOCIETY.
IT INSULATES THE INSTITUTION
FROM PUBLIC SCRUTINY LEADING
SCHOOLS LEFT COMPELLED TO TRULY
SELF REFLECT AND MAKE THE
NECESSARY REFORMS TO PREVENT
THESE CRIMES AND PROTECT FUTURE
VICTIMS. ALL ADULTS WORK IN A
SCHOOL HAVE A STICKER INSCRIBED
LEGAL DUTY TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN. WHEN SEX CRIMES TAKE
PLACE IN THE SCHOOL CONTEXT
EVERYONE AGREES THAT SOMETHING
HAD GONE HORRIBLY WRONG. WHAT
SHOULD THOSE ONES GO
UNINVESTIGATED AS A CONSEQUENCE
OF PARENTS AGREEING NOT TO SUE
THE SCHOOL FOR GRADES ARE
PARKING. REGARDLESS OF THE
AMERICAN ARBITRATION OF ANY
CLOGGING THE COURTS SHOULD SEX
CRIMES AGAINST SCHOOL CHILDREN
SPEAK AUTOMATICALLY COVERED
BEHIND THE CLOAK OF
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION. AT
THE WHITE LONG CITIZENS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ASK HOW
WE DID ACCEPTABLE THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW AND ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT SIGNED BY PARENTS OF
THE REQUIRED CONDITION FOR THE
CHILDREN TO ATTEND SCHOOL CAN
OPERATE THE HIGH TECH CRIME OR
OTHER HIGH FELONIES. BEHIND
CONFIDENTIAL ARBITRATION WE
IMPLORE YOU TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE BY TAPPING AB TWO
SEVEN TWO INTO LAW PREVENTS
SCHOOLS FROM FORCING RAPE
VICTIMS INTO ARBITRATION BASED
ON DECEPTIVE AND WANTED THE
CREAMY. HAVING AB TWO SEVEN
FOUR THE BOOKS WILL LAW WAY
TOWARD HELPING OUR CHILD FEEL
BY KNOWING OTHER CHILDREN WILL
NOT BAKER SIMILARLY PAINFUL
SACRAMENTO AGAIN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WHICH INTEL THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR AB TWO
SEVENTY TWO WILL TAKE NAME.
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO SEVENTY
TWO CONTRACTS ONE THEN ZERO AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH THE ONLINE NUMBER AND HE
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO SEVENTY TWO. POINT FIVE
FOUR ONE ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT
HERE WE HAVE TWO PARTICIPANTS
IN Q. MY NUMBER TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIFTEEN ATTACK CARLA THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER SIXTY
FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU TELL YOUR
BALANCE THE CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE- IN SUPPORT. AND AT
THIS TIME MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU.
REMOVED OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
LISTED OPPOSITION WITNESS
ROBERT MUTRIE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IS ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. I AM INTERJECTED
MORNING MORNING. IT'S FAR WILL
IT ROBERT MCCREE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY TWO ALL
UP FRONT I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR WE IN NO WAY CONDONE ANY
FORM OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
MOST CERTAINLY CONDEMN- THE ACT
WERE DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY BUT
INDIVIDUALS CERTAINLY SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED AT BY THE HERE THAT-
INDIVIDUAL LOT- ALSO OPPOSITION
IS NOT BASED ON ANYTHING TO
COMICS THEIR SCHOOLS- THAT'S
NOT WHY WE ARE. IN A POSITION
TODAY OUR SOLE CONCERN HERE AT
ARBITRATION ILLEGAL SANDERS THE
JURISPRUDENCE AROUND IT- I
THANK STOP WITH A THOROUGH
ANALYSIS ON THE POINT- SIMPLY
PUT AS TOO SIMILAR TO THE BILLS
FROM LAST YEAR- WE BELIEVE THIS
IS PREEMPTED AND APPRECIATE THE
OFFICE AWARE THAT THAT THE FAA
HERE- BUT WE DO NOT BELIEVE THE
EXCEPTIONS ARE THE ACTIONS OF
THE FACTORS IDENTIFIED BY
NUMBER KILEY INSTANT COMMENT.
ALL RECOGNIZING THE RELEVANT
JURISPRUDENCE- THE GENERAL CASE
MATTER AT&T MOBILITY
CONCEPCION- THERE THE CUTS THE
COURT SPOKE QUITE CLEARLY THE
FAA PERMIT AGREEMENTS TO
ARBITRATE TO BE INVALIDATED BY
QUOTE GENERALLY APPLICABLE
CONTRACT SPENT SUCH AS FRAUD
DIRECTOR UNCONSCIOUS BUT NOT BY
THE FACT THAT THAT APPLY ONLY
TO ARBITRATION OR DRIVE THEIR
MEANING. TO THE FACT THAT
AGREEMENT ARBITRATED ISSUE. WE
DO THIS LEGISLATION AT THE TO
THE THAT I DEPEND TO GIVE IT TO
OUR WHICH- AND- A- THROUGH CORN
CONTENT YEAH- AT THAT'S NOT
CLEAR WE AGREED EXAMPLE OF
TOMORROW IS AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY INTO FOURTEEN WHICH TO.
WHAT PREDATOR ARBITRATION FOR
PARTICULAR TYPE OF CLAIM THERE
SO RIGHTS ADJUSTER ALSO. ORTON
BUT THEY ARE AND I THINK THIS
NOW KNOWS THAT HELP WILL PUBLIC
HELD. IN THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT DECLINED TO REVIEW THAT
DECISION AT BEST HE WAITED
PATIENTLY JUST PATTED ME NOW
WITH AND OUR LETTER- SO. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL DOES
EXACTLY ABSOLUTE CONSIDER TO
THOSE CASES IT IS PREEMPTIVE
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY APPROACHED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ARE ARE PRETTY
MUCH OPEN LINES FOR ANYONE ELSE.
TO REGISTER OPPOSITION TO AB
TWO SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR INTERMENT IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY TWO PERFECT
ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB. TWO
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ZERO NOW. AND THAT IS HOW MUCH
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE Q.
RIGHT. THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE THE LINES OF BRING IT
BACK TO. THE COMMITTEE AND MR
KILEY IS THIS BILL WENT THROUGH
LAST YEAR TOO I THINK WE NOTED
THAT. I CERTAINLY WISH YOU
SUCCESS WITH THIS WE'VE BEEN
LONG PROBING. THE BOUNDARIES OF
ARBITRATION WHICH DO END UP
WITH SOME PRETTY UNCONSCIONABLE
RESULTS AND IF THIS IS A PATH
TO HELPING. DELINEATE HOW WE
CAN BETTER THINK OF WHERE A
STATE MAY ENTER THIS
CONVERSATION- THE BETTER OFF I
THINK WE ALL ARE SO I AM VERY
HOPEFUL THAT. THIS BILL WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP ESTABLISH SOME OF
THOSE BOUNDS. AS AS WELL AS A
POINTS OUT. THE WE'VE ALSO.
DONE WORK AROUND SECRET
SETTLEMENTS IN THIS LEGISLATURE
AND TRIED BECAUSE OF THE
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT OF. KEEPING
THAT INFORMATION AWAY FROM THE
PUBLIC WHO NEED TO BE AWARE OF
THE FACT THAT SOME OF THESE.
SETTLEMENTS ARE HAPPENING AND
HAPPENING BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
AWAY FROM THE PUBLIC THEN NOT
ALERTING THE PUBLIC OF THE
DANGERS OF A PARTICULAR
SITUATION SO. I CERTAINLY WISH
YOU WELL WITH THIS BILL AND-
HOPE THAT IT WILL MOVE OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS AMID
GONZALEZ. GRAYSON KALRA. I JUST
WANNA AGREE WITH THE CHAIR- I
THINK WHAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
ON I'M ON RECORD THOUGH THAT I
DISAGREE WITH THE ANALYSIS THAT
THIS IS- UNIQUE ONLY TO SCHOOLS
AND CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT.
ALTHOUGH IT IS- DEPLORABLE IN
PROBABLY THE MOST. EGREGIOUS OF
CASES- ARBITRATION HIDES SERIAL
ABUSERS IN EVERY FORM IN THE
WORK PLACE IN SCHOOLS AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND IT IT BRINGS
TO LIGHT. EXACTLY WHY
ARBITRATION- CAN BE SUCH A
FAILURE FOR VICTIMS THE FACT
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO- AN
ARBITRATOR DOES NOT HAVE TO
BASE THEIR DECISION ON LAW IT
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD ALL BE SHOCKED ABOUT. NO
MATTER WHAT THE CLAIM IS AND SO
AS SOMEBODY WHO OBVIOUSLY HAS
DONE BILLS- BOTH ON ARBITRATION
AND EXTENDING THE TIME LIMIT
FOR- INDIVIDUALS TO PURSUE
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT
CLAIMS. THAT UP I WOULD LIKE
COOPER THIS BILL I OF COURSE
SUPPORTED- I'LL MOVE IT BUT I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
TODAY- IN RESPONSE TO THIS.
POOR CHILD- AND- INABILITY TO
GET JUSTICE COULD COULD BE
MAGNIFIED BY. A WOMAN IN THE
WORKPLACE COULD BE MAGNIFIED
BY- YOU KNOW OTHER CHILDREN AT
OTHER ACTIVITIES- OR OR EVEN
ADULTS AND SO I JUST I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW THAT
THAT- I APPRECIATE YOU TRYING
TO NARROWLY TAILOR THIS TO
STAND UP TO TRADITIONAL
REVEALED. I THINK IT HIGHLIGHTS
THE PROBLEM IN GENERAL WITH
ARBITRATION SOUND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORWARD. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A THAT IS A CO AUTHOR. WE
DO HAVE A MOTION IS THEIR
SECOND ATTEMPT. IN A SECOND
THANK YOU SERVICE RADIUS. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR INTO WAS GONZALEZ FOR THE
COMMENTS I THINK WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MANDATORY
ARBITRATION CLAUSE WE ARE
TELLING PEOPLE TO GIVE UP YOUR
RIGHTS BEFORE YOU EVEN KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE A RIGHT. AND THAT
THAT HAS BEEN EIGHT EIGHT A
SERIOUS ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
DEALT WITH IN THE LAW- IN
TRYING TO HELP VICTIMS AT THE
END I AGREE THAT IF THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP IT'S I APPLAUD IT
AND I HOPE THAT IT DOESN'T GET
STUCK IN EVEN THOUGH SENATE
JUDICIARY LIKE LAST TIME BUT IT
HAD TO DO WITH COVERT AS
OPPOSED TO THE MERITS OF. OF
THE BILL AND I HOPE THAT THAT
THIS TIME IT DOES GO THROUGH
YOU YOU SPOKE THROUGH GRITTED
SPOKE ABOUT THE UNCONSCIONABLE
T. IN THAT THAT STILL IS A TEST
AT UNFORTUNATELY EVEN IN SOME
OF THE OTHER CASES WHERE YOU
HAVE MANDATORY CONFIDENTIAL
ARBITRATION CLAUSES THE PEOPLE
SIGN ON TO THEY THEY THEY AGREE
TO THEM. BECAUSE THEY ARE IN NO
POSITION NOT TO AGREE TO THEM
THEY WANT THAT JOB THEY WANT
THAT MEDICAL TREATMENT AND SO
THE AGREE TO THE USE MANDATORY
ARBITRATION CLAUSE THAT SIMPLY
TAKE AWAY EVERY RIGHT THEY
COULD POSSIBLY HAVE IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE OF THE IT IS A
AS A RESULT OF THE MALFEASANCE
OF THE PERSON. THAT IS THE
BENEFICIARY OF THAT ARBITRATION
CLAUSE BUT I DO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND FOR THAT SCHWARTZ
FAMILY I AM SO SORRY FOR WHAT
THEY WENT THROUGH- FOR THEIR
CHILD AND I HOPE THAT BECAUSE
OF THIS THERE WILL BE CHANGES
FOR THOSE CHILDREN AND THOSE
PARENTS OF CHILDREN IN THE
FUTURE THAT GO THROUGH THE SAME
THING BUT ALSO FOR. THE OTHERS
WHO ARE ALSO AFFECTED BY THESE
MANDATORY ARBITRATION CLAUSES
THANK YOU AND I'D ALSO I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR IF YOU SO- FIND THAT
WOULD BE OF COURSE THANK. YOU
MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU SURE
YOU SOME KILEY PERSON SINCE
NUMBER THIS FOR- A- JUST ALL
THE COMMENTS AND- PARTICULARLY
THE- COMMENTS REGARDING THE
POWER IMBALANCE THAT EXISTS- IN
IN SIGNING OF THESE CONTRACTS
AND SIGNING AWAY YOUR RIGHTS.
IN ORDER TO HAVE A JOB IN ORDER
TO HAVE YOUR CHILD GO TO
SCHOOL. AND SO- THOSE COMMENTS
REALLY RESONATE WITH ME-
CERTAINLY IN MY SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AND I WOULD ALSO SAY I DO
BELIEVE THERE IS A SICK
RELATIONSHIP IN TERMS OF YOUR
SEND YOUR CHILD TO SCHOOL. OF
ALL PLACES YOU KNOW THAT THAT I
THINK THAT I THINK WE HAVE A
VISCERAL. EMOTION WE HEAR ABOUT
ANYTHING HAPPENING TO CHILDREN
AT THEIR SCHOOL I WANT TO GO TO
SCHOOL THERE. IT'S IT IS
ESPECIALLY- IT KINDA
EMOTIONALLY. AIM FOR A I THINK
THAT. IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
ONE INDIVIDUAL VICTIM BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT. BY NOT
ALLOWING. THESE THESE INSIDIOUS
SITUATIONS TO- REPETITIVE TO
HAVE SUNLIGHT SHINED ON THEM.
YOUR ALLOWING CONDUCT IN THESE
INSTITUTIONS TO CONTINUE IN
MANY CASES FOR MANY MANY YEARS
WITH MANY MANY VICTIMS. AND SO
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO TRY TO NOT
ONLY BRING- SOME SENSE OF
JUSTICE TO AN INDIVIDUAL TO
DUMP IN MANY CASES COULD
PREVENT. MANY MANY OTHER
VICTIMS- WHEN YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWING THAT SUN. TO SHINE IN
SORT OF SPEAK. AND SO IN THAT
REGARD I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT. IN THE IN THIS KIND
OF ENVIRONMENT ALTHOUGH I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH MY-
COLLEAGUES THAT I DO BELIEVE
THAT. THE THIS FORCED MANDATORY
ARBITRATION- IMPLICATES THEM
WITH THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
MANY OTHER WINDOWS- IN THIS
CASE- THE HOPE IS THAT. WILL
PREVENT CHILD VICTIMS- GOING
FORWARD- IN INSTITUTIONS THAT
BUT RATHER. EVERYTHING'S UNDER.
INAPPROPRIATE THINGS UNDER THE
RUG RATHER THAN ACTUALLY
ALLOWING. FOR PUBLIC VENUES TO
HAVE THEM. THE TICKET. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THIS GALLAGHER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND YEAH I KNOW
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS
IN THIS COMMITTEE- A LEFT OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS ABOUT
ARBITRATION YOU KNOW AND AS I
THINK WHAT COMMONLY COMES UP AS
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE'S BEEF IS
WITH THE FAA WITH THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT- AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE NOT
FEDERAL LEGISLATOR LEGISLATORS
WERE MORE STATE LEGISLATURES
MAYBE WHEN MEMBERS NAY BECAUSE
GO TO CONGRESS ONE DAY. THEY
COULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
AND CHANGE THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT BUT THAT IS
WHAT REALLY GETS IN THE WAY OF
BEING ABLE TO MAKE THE SUCH
CHANGES IT IT DOES- YOU KNOW.
WE'RE SORT OF SUPERSEDED BY
THAT LAW- I THINK MR KILEY HAS.
DONE A GOOD JOB OF SHOWING WHY
IN THIS CASE THAT WOULD NOT
APPLY- MOST NOTABLY BECAUSE
WE'RE DEALING WITH MINORS HERE.
AND THAT MINORS CANNOT SIGN
AWAY THEIR RIGHTS- THAT'S VERY
CLEAR IN MANY DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF THE LAW- AND- YOUR LOOK
ARBITRATION I THINK. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE POINTED OUT
DIFFERENT THINGS ABOUT IT BUT
IT THERE ARE BENEFITS STARBIRD
TRADITION. IN TERMS OF
EFFICIENCIES IN TERMS OF
ENSURING- QUICK ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ACTUALLY BECAUSE OUR
COURTS AS WE KNOW ARE NOT
ALWAYS SO QUICK. AND LET'S NOT
SAID THEY'RE ALWAYS SUNSHINY
ESPECIALLY HERE RECENTLY WHEN
THEY HAVE AN EMAIL ON THE
PUBLIC- AND THE MANY COURT
COURT ROOMS- WHEN JURY TRIALS
HAVE BEEN DELAYED- AND PEOPLE
HAVEN'T HAD. FOR INSTANCE QUICK
JURY TRIALS- IN THE STATE LET'S
NOT ACT LIKE OUR COURT SYSTEM
IS SO OPEN AND TRANSPARENT
BECAUSE IT. IT ACTUALLY HAS NOT
BEEN IN MANY CASES- BUT YOU
KNOW I THINK WHAT WE'RE GETTING
THAT- IS THAT THE ISSUE THAT IT
SEEMS UNFAIR- WHEN- ESPECIALLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT QUEER SCENE
SOMEONE INTO AN AGREEMENT.
OFTENTIMES ARE TALKING ABOUT
ADULTS YOU BECOME AN EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD YOU'RE AN ADULT. YOU
CAN MAKE ADULT DECISIONS YOU
CAN DECIDE WHERE YOU WANT TO
WORK YOU CAN DECIDE- SOME THESE
DIFFERENT WHAT CONTRACTS YOU
WANT TO ENTER INTO AND NOT
ENTER INTO- THAT'S A DIFFERENT
CONTEXT IN THE ONE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. RIGHT HERE- WE'RE
WE HAVE MINORS WHO WHO HAVE TO
GO TO SCHOOL ARE LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO BY THE WAY- AND WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO BE GETTING AN
EDUCATION- AND THEN HAVING
THIS- BE IMPOSED UPON THEM
AGAINST THEIR WILL. AND AS WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WITH A
DIFFERENT BILL PEOPLE AND POWER
PEOPLE THAT ARE GIVEN POWER AND
STEWARDSHIP. I YOU KNOW- TO
ALLOW THEM TO ABUSE THAT POWER
AND THEN BASICALLY HIDE BEHIND
SOMETHING IS NOT OK AND I THINK
WE'VE ACTUALLY MIGHT BE
THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW LOOKING
AT YOU KNOW OVERWHELMINGLY
OBVIOUSLY OUR TEACHERS DO AN
AMAZING JOB OF PROTECTING OUR
KIDS OF TEACHING THEM- BUT
THERE ARE SOME PRETTY EGREGIOUS
EXAMPLES OF TEACHERS WHO HAVE
ABUSED THEIR POWER- AND HAVE
VIOLATED CHILDREN'S LOT RIGHTS
AND- HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HIDE
BEHIND DIFFERENT THINGS IN THE
SYSTEM. AND EVEN GOOD GET
TRANSFERRED TO OTHER PLACES
WHERE THEY CONTINUE TO DO THE
SAME EXACT THING- WE'VE
HIGHLIGHTED THAT IN OTHER AREAS
OF OUR SOCIETY I THINK WE NEED
TO START FOCUSING ON IT. IN
THIS PART OF OUR SOCIETY AS
WELL- SO I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS- AND- THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING AFFORD. THE
STATE. THANK YOU MISTER KELLY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS BILL
I. YOU KNOW I THINK IF YOU
REALLY WERE TO TAKE OUT OF YOU
KNOW A POLL AND ASK PARENTS HOW
MANY OF THEM. ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY DO IN A
ROLE MEANT THAT THIS WOULD BE
PART OF IT THAT IF SOMETHING
HAPPENED TO THEIR CHILD THAT
THEY REALLY WANT TO HAVE- VOICE
THERE. THEY'D BE QUITE SHOCKED
SO I APPRECIATE THIS- I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I WOULD BE
HONORED TO BE PART OF A CO
AUTHOR. YES OF COURSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT THANK YOU AGAIN
MR KILEY AND I THINK IT IS OUR
OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE TO PRO
FEDERAL POLICIES THAT WE FIND
THAT ARE INEFFECTIVE OR
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR CITIZENRY.
GET APPLIED YOUR- PERSISTENCE
IN THIS AREA AND WITH THAT YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THAT. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS TO PASS CALDERON
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE CHAU.
CHAU CHIU. DAVIES DAVEY SIDE
AND SALAS GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
RACE FIVE REASSIGN. RIGHT THANK
YOU THAT BILLS OUT WE HAVE ONE
MORE BILL AND THAT IS MY BILL
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHT. MR
GALLAGHER DO. RUN THIS YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU ARE
PRESENT TEAM. AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN YES THEY BECAUSE CRAZY
EIGHTEEN. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
MEMBERS IS IT TAKES AN ACTION.
ABOUT A MINOR WHO IS CHANGING
NAME OR GENDER WHICH IS
GENERALLY REQUIRED TO BE DONE
OUT IN CIVIL COURT WHEN THERE
ARE. USUALLY THESE ARE ACTIONS
THAT WERE WENT WHEN THAT CHILD
IS INVOLVED IN THE JUVENILE
COURT WHICH IS A MUCH MORE
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR AN ACTION
LIKE THIS TO HAPPEN SO THIS
BILL DOES IS ALLOW. THEIR
ATTORNEY TO BRING THIS ACTION
IN JUVENILE COURT AND HAVE ALL
OF THE BENEFITS AND THE
PROTECTIONS THAT JUVENILE COURT
REPRESENTS. THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND THE OTHER ASPECT
OF IT BECAUSE OF THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS FOR JUVENILES IS IT
DELETES THE REQUIREMENT THAT
USUALLY WHEN THERE'S A NAME
CHANGER A GENDER CHANGE THAT
THAT HAPPENED A TO BE PUBLISHED
IN A NEWSPAPER OF RECORD SINCE
HE SAID THIS WOULD THEN BE A
JUVENILE COURT PROCEEDING THAT
WOULD NOT HAPPEN. BUT ALL OF
THE OTHER NOTIFICATIONS
INCLUDING NOTIFICATIONS TO
PARENTS WOULD STILL HAPPEN ALL
THIS DOES IS WOULD PRECLUDE THE
PUBLIC NOTICE BECAUSE IT'S A
PART OF PROTECTING THAT CHILD
THERE ARE I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MIKE BELOW
FROM THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND JUDGE ROBERT
CHAN. REPRESENTING THE JUVENILE
COURT JUDGES OF CALIFORNIA
BOTH. ARE AVAILABLE ON THE
TELEPHONE AND- I ASK FOR YOUR
RECIPE YOU'RE EITHER. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WE DO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES I BELIEVE IN AND
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE MIKE BELOW
FROM THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND ROGER CHAN.
FROM THE JUVENILE COURT JUDGES
THE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IT IS MIKE
FOLLOWED UP FOR THE JUVENILE
COURT JUDGES OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS A SECTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
I'LL BE BRIEF THE OTHER THING
CAN SEEM COMPLICATED BECAUSE IT
DEALS WITH BOTH GENDER AND NAME
CHANGE PETITIONS. AND THEN THE
JUVENILE COURT HAS TO AREAS
THAT HAVE THE DEPENDENCY LAW
AND THE DELINQUENCY CLOCK. I
LIKE TO THINK OF THIS AS
AFFECTING JURISDICTION
CLARIFYING THAT THE JUVENILE
COURT IS THE PROPER
JURISDICTION FOR- BOTH A GENDER
AND NAME CHANGE PETITIONS- FOR
DELINQUENCY JUST AS IT IS NOW
IN THE LAW OR DEPENDENCY- THIS
MAKES SENSE FOR THE YOUTH AND
IT ALSO MAKES SENSE FOR SOCIETY
YOU WANT PEOPLE IN THE JUVENILE
COURT HANDLING THESE MATTERS.
SO YOU DON'T GET CONFUSION
BETWEEN THE JUVENILE COURT AND
THE CIVIL COURT. ASKED
PUBLICATION- ALL THE BILL DOES
IS SAY THAT FOR BOTH- FORD NAME
CHANGE ONLY WE'VE ALREADY YOU
HAVE ALREADY HANDLED THE GENDER
CHANGE ISSUE. BUT ADDS TO THE
NAME CHANGE ONLY. IT PRECLUDES
PUBLICATION- FOR BOTH
DEPENDENCY AND DELINQUENCY TO
PROTECT THE PRIVACY OF THE
MINOR AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW THAT
JUVENILE COURT PROCEEDINGS ARE
PRESUMPTIVELY CLOSED. BECAUSE
OF THE SENSITIVE NATURE OF THE-
YOUTH INVOLVED SO IT WE THINK
IT'S STRAIGHTFORWARD IT
CLARIFIES JURISDICTION AND
REMOVES PUBLICATION ON NAME
CHANGE PETITION- I. HAVE JUDGE
ROGER CHAN ON THE LINE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
IF THEY ARISE AND WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. OKAY OPERATOR YOU CAN
YOU OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY-
PERSONS WANTING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT. FOR A BI THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE TWO ZERO. IT WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH DEADLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. SOME OF THE
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY- ANYWAY. I DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- BUT
ARE THERE ANYBODY ON THE HONES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO AB THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN COULD PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE IT BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN. PLUS PLUS
ONE ZERO NOW. AT THE TIME OF
THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
OKAY- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. NOT JUST ONE QUESTION I
HAD A MAYBE IT'S- FOR THE
WITNESSES- RIGHT NOW LIKE IF
YOU JUST IF A MINOR IS
PRIVATELY GOING TO COURT TO DO
A NAME CHANGE THAT WOULD HAVE
TO BE PUBLISHED RIGHT- SO WHY
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOU KNOW
SOMEONE WHO IS NOT CURRENTLY
AWARDED EITHER DELINQUENCY
YEAR. OR- DEPENDENCY. THEN THE
NORMAL PERSON- YOU KNOW THE
CHILD THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
COURT MONEY TO CHANGE OUR CO
WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE TO PUBLISH
IT. BECAUSE IF. THEY'RE NOT THE
WORD OF THE COURT IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCE THEY'RE NOT
TECHNICALLY ON THE JURISDICTION
OF THE JUVENILE COURT SO THEY
DON'T GET THOSE PROTECTIONS I
DON'T DISAGREE THAT THAT WOULD
BE. A GOOD CHANGE I THINK THE
REQUIREMENT ESPECIALLY FOR
JUVENILE TO HAVE TO PUBLISH
PUBLICLY THAT THE NAME CHANGE.
IS ARGUABLY PROBLEMATIC WOULD
BE WE SHOULD BE WORKING TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND IN
COULD BE PROTECTED WE'RE JUST
DEALING WITH THE CASE WHERE THE
CHILD IS IN. THE DELINQUENCY
PROCESS AND IF THEY WANT TO DO
A NAME CHANGE THEY HAVE TO GO.
OUTSIDE OF THAT PROCESS TO
CIVIL COURT TO. MAKE THAT
PETITION. IF THIS BILL PASSES
THAT WOULD ALL STATE WITHIN THE
JUVENILE COURTS THAT'S THE FEES
WERE TRYING TO SOLVE HERE. YOUR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OKAY- WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU LIKE
CLOSE AS FOR YOUR EVENT- MADAM
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTIONS TO PASS STONE FIVE
STONE I GALLAGHER. CHAU HI CHAO
AYE CHIU DAVIES. NOT VOTING.
CONSOL FIVE GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. CALL AYE
KILEY. MAIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES FIVE YES I. THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
RIGHT WE HAVE COMPLETED THE
BUSINESS ALL BILLS ARE OUT BUT
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO THEN IS GO
BACK THROUGH THE LIST SEEMS TO
MAKE SENSE HERE AND MEMBERS CAN
VOTE ON BILLS THAT THEY WERE
ABSENT FOR. SO START WITH THE
CONSENT AGENDA. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS AYE
REYES AT. THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
ONE A. B. TEN TWENTY FRIEDMAN.
CHIU MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
ADAM NUMBER TWO IS A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN GABRIEL.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES YES I
DON'T NUMBER THREE IS AB TEN
NINETY SIX RIVAS CHIU
MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHENNAI. I
REMEMBER FOR IS AB FOUR OH NINE
SAWYER TO. CHIU HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHENNAI. BUT
OF NUMBER FIVE IS AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY FIVE WORKS TO HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I KIND OF NUMBER
SIX IS AB TWO SEVENTY TWO
KILEY. TO MAIN CHIANG MAI
CHENNAI. AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AND THE- AND WE HAVE I
THINK JUST MISTER TO. OKAY SO
THANK YOU ALL ARE WE IS MR. TO
COMING BACK DO WE KNOW THE
WHOLE THE WORLD OPEN FOR A FEW
MINUTES AND SEE IF WE CAN GET
MISTER TO. COMING BACK TO
COMPLETE THE VOTING. SO. YEAH.
RIGHT. ALL. THE LITTLE. MERMAID
ALL YEAH. THE ISSUE OF SIX
BILLS YEAH YOU GUYS KNOW. THE
MOVIES OKAY SO. THE. THIS IS.
WITH BROKEN THAT. PERFECT RIGHT
SO WHAT SHOULD WE NEED TO ONE
SIX BILLS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
TEN TWENTY FRIEDMAN CHIU CHU I
THINK WE HAVE YOU ON ITEM
NUMBER TWO ITEM NUMBER THREE A.
B. TEN NINETY SIX RIVAS CHU CHU
I REMEMBER FOR A BEFORE- NINE
SERRA. CHIU I TO II. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE WEEKS CHU. JULY I NUMBER
SIX A. B. SEVENTY KILEY CHIU
CHU I AND NUMBER SEVEN AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN STONE CHIP TO
I. GOOD PERFECT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED.